testing one two
this meeting will start in one or two
minutes we're waiting for the prime
sponsor of the first bill we're going to
hear in public hearing and so we'll
delay the start of the meeting until the
prime sponsor arrives
okay ladies and gentlemen I think we'll
get started uh there's some confusion
about
who will introduce the first bill at
public hearing here this morning
there there may be some confusion about
the room because originally this meeting
was scheduled to be in a room downstairs
it got revised so that we could meet
here and some people may not have gotten
the message
if you wouldn't mind thank you so we're
going to double check uh
to make sure we didn't lose some folks
by having them go to the wrong room
and
when we get an assurance that everybody
who is supposed to be here is in fact
here then we will start thank you
for those of you waiting or watching at
home we're waiting for the prime sponsor
of this bill to make an appearance
we'll wait another few minutes if uh
representative cretian
does not appear then we will
have someone else introduce the bill
so please be patient for another minute
or two thank you
okay we have uh verified that there are
no people in the wrong room
so
and no bills or anything else
the clerk is looking for me
oh the clerk is looking for the bill the
bills okay
all right
so it would appear that we can begin
this meeting so as usual we will begin
our meeting by all rising and joining
representative Doug Thomas as he leads
us in the Pledge of Allegiance
and justice for all
okay thank you everyone
welcome to the Thursday January of
February 16th meeting of science
technology and energy we are here this
morning to hear two bills House Bill 631
FN relative to electric utility smart
meter Gateway devices
followed by hb159 relative to the
default service rate for electricity
we will then be taking a lunch break and
a caucus break
and will return at one o'clock for an
executive session
at which we will pass judgment on a
fairly large number of bills both
scheduled today and resumed from
earlier executive sessions
so with that I'll open a public hearing
on House Bill 631
and the prime sponsor representative
Christian is not here so we will ask
representative Corman to introduce this
legislation to us
thank you Mr chairman and again welcome
uh or hello members of the committee for
the record I'm representative Tom Corman
Grafton 15 which is Lebanon ward 3 I'm
here to introduce HB 631fn
uh we have heard many people say this is
a simple bill this is a simple bill it
says that electric utilities shall
provide customers with the option to
purchase a smart meter Gateway device to
be installed removed or Changed by
authorized utility Personnel or approved
contractors and Electric utilities shall
notify customers of this option so it is
not forcing any customers to have a
smart meter it just makes sure that
everybody has the option currently of
the four utilities serving the state two
of them make smart meters available and
two do not the two that do not are ever
source and Liberty I'm a liberty
customer and I don't have the option of
having a smart meter
so just to be clear what we're talking
about isn't just AMR meters the type
that are the drive-by reporting device
we're talking about the ones that are
actually two-way meters where the
information actually can go back to the
utility about things like time of use so
that time of use charging can actually
be in effect for certain customers which
will be even more important as EVS
become more dominant in the state
because people are going to want to be
able to charge their EVS at times with
lower rates typically overnight
um and
um
again we're not talking about anybody
being forced to do anything any
customers being forced to do anything
we're just saying that that the
utilities need to make this option
available
um
there's really not much else I can say
about it uh
I'm happy to take questions
for representative Corman
on behalf of Representative Christian
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chair
um so is there any uh expectation on
whether the cost of the meter would be
added to the customer's bill or uh
Incorporated in the overall cost of
elect electric just electric electricity
distribution across the utility
thank you representative Bernardi my
understanding is that the customer would
pay for the meter so it wouldn't be
charged to other people if I want a
smart meter I pay for it it's about two
hundred dollars to have a smart meter so
via at my option that's my understanding
of how it works thank you very much
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
Tom uh as far as you understand does the
does the bill pretty much leave the
specification decide who decides
um
which piece of equipment
the customer would get is that basically
all in the hands of the utility to sort
of do the research and figure out which
which meter they want to have customers
own
so my understanding is that from the
text of the bill it does not specify any
particular type of meter it just says
smart meter Gateway device so that I
would imagine the utility can decide
what type to offer
thanks
as a follow-up to that question
does the customer get to choose what
kind of meter he wants
does he get to specify to the utility oh
I want XYZ meter instead of ABC meter
so that I do not know uh I would imagine
that each utility can support some range
of meters some set of meters it might be
one type might be a few types
uh I would imagine then that the utility
would make available to the customer you
know here here are the types of meters
that we can support and then the
customer can choose because it would
certainly make sense that
it has to be something that the utility
can interact with right I mean if we're
talking about something where you know
the information has to get back to the
utility
the utility has to be able to field that
information so I would imagine that
there's some set of approved meters
we have someone signed up from
eversource to testify so we can ask that
question there
any further questions thank you
representative Corman for stepping up
and pinch hitting for representative
Christian we appreciate it thank you
chair both
please do a pink card just for the
record thank you next we'll call on Mr
Michael Licata from eversource to give
us the utilities perspective on this
legislation
welcome
good morning
um Michael Licata representing
eversource energy I appreciate the
opportunity to testify before you today
on this legislation
um
I am registering our opposition to the
bill uh that said we are uh you know
very supportive of uh customers ability
to access
um
more detailed pricing excuse me more
detailed usage information and the
expansion of
smart meters in the state of New
Hampshire we definitely appreciate the
the Bill's sponsors intent
um but I'll sort of lay out our our
concerns with the bill as written first
and foremost the bill directs the
utility to provide upon customer Quest
smart Gateway devices smart Gateway
devices are actually different than Ami
or smart meters a smart Gateway device
is a device that allows and enables load
control behind the meter so think of a
demand response program where the
utility has the ability to reduce your
uh uh thermostat or control your water
heater at times of peak use so they are
two separate
types of of infrastructure the Gateway
device versus a smart meter which
um as was described allows for more
granular
information on time of use
so the intent of the bill though which
I'll speak to is to allow for a customer
to request a smart meter an Ami meter as
two of the other utilities have and just
by way of background as part of
eversource most recent Ray case we did
agree as part of the settlement with
parties including the Office of Consumer
Advocate who advocated for this
to conduct a study a feasibility study
looking at the the cost of implementing
and swapping out our current AMR meters
with AMI meters we are in the process of
selecting a vendor to conduct that study
we have issued an RFP and we are
receiving those responses back now our
expectation is that we'll be selecting a
vendor next month and that will take
maybe three to four months to conduct
that feasibility study that we'll look
at the costs and impacts of of changing
our meters uh out so that process is in
place as well or moving forward I should
say as well and really the the Crux of
the issue for for us is um
you know it's not just the meter in
order to enable either a smart Gateway
devices functionality or an Ami meters
functionality there are systems that the
utility has that need to be to enable
that functionality so right now our
current systems don't have the ability
to to enable that functionality and so
we would need to and this will be part
of of the review uh need to change our
meter management system we would need to
change our customer information system
and potentially billing systems so it is
more involved than simply changing out a
meter and then the customer being able
to to access that that information that
said again I I very much appreciate the
bill sponsor's intent
um we are moving forward on a number of
um areas to address this concern to have
have Smart metering or or more granular
metering available so with that I'll be
happy to answer any questions that the
committee may have
thank you Mr locata representative Doug
Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh to clarify your
last statement
did you mean to imply that if you need
to do all these systems I assume there
would be upgrades and things like that
would
the cost of that be included in your
next rate height consideration
whenever we
change those systems out the costs
associated with that would be included
in in our next radius I don't know if it
would be the next one or the one after
that their significant undertakings uh
and there's a lot to consider as part of
of replacement of those systems you
obviously want the customer to
experience a seamless transition and
there's many utilities across the
country that have had challenges they're
very complicated systems
follow-up thank you Miss Champion for
the follow-up
so in other words if say um
one percent or even five percent of your
customers wanted the new meter
um
even though they they may have to pay
individually for that meter everybody in
your in your area would be settled with
the expense of upgrading the system to
provide that functionality
um that's a fair question
I'm not sure how we would interpret
the language in the bill if we simply
need to provide the meter so that way
the customer would I'm sorry the smart
Gateway device or if it were amended the
the meter so that way the customer would
be sort of ready
um the first one in line so to speak
when uh those systems were changed out
or if this I
or if this would require us to to do
those system upgrades it's I I don't
think it's clear by the legislation
so for clarity for clarification as a
follow-up
you mentioned an RFP to
conduct a study cost study on all of
this upgrades meters plus back room
system upgrades
I assume the study would include those
back room upgrades correct I I want to
double check that I know the study is
looking at the meters themselves I I
would be happy to get back to the
committee to to make sure I'm giving you
an accurate answer on that
okay thank you representative Bernardi
has a question
so uh just to be clear your study is
looking at uh meters and potentially the
back room systems but not Gateway
devices as this bill is discussing
that's correct thank you
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um
eversource is a very large utility
of course also in in Connecticut and in
Massachusetts uh Mr Lakota can you tell
us
to what extent
um
smart metering time of use rates things
like that are already in place in
Connecticut and Massachusetts
is eversource doing this elsewhere
that's sure
um we in Massachusetts uh in November of
last year received approval from the
regulator to to do this change to go
from AMR meters to Ami meters so that
process has has begun there is a
stakeholder group that that order
requires us to to create and advise with
that stakeholder group is supposed to
issue a report on essentially the
rollout plan of those meter swaps uh by
I believe it's August of next year so
correct 2024 so that process is is
ongoing I would in terms of the actual
meter swaps themselves all of those sort
of back office systems again need to be
changed
and that process is is moving forward
now now in Massachusetts I need to check
in on Connecticut but I think they are
behind Massachusetts as is New Hampshire
from uh uh you know moving forward
standpoint so uh that process we just
again just got approval for uh the
change in Massachusetts to go to Ami and
it's moving forward now
follow up
if
I mean our bill here says a smart meter
Gateway device so from what you've said
I'm I'm interpreting that you feel like
that's a
an exact kind of a mashup of two
different things uh
is there a risk well it's not a risk for
us because we're not going there but
um
is there an opportunity
you mentioned the study uh came out of
the rate case you're putting out an RFP
to look at the possibility of going to
am I
uh it feels like that's a
by the time we get to implementing Ami
the state of the art Maybe
Gateway devices that allow actually
allow
the utility to see and perhaps control
within customers territory you know load
and is there a question here yeah I
guess I'm I I guess my question would be
is eversource looking at the quickly
evolving technology in the utility space
and thinking about a way to perhaps
LeapFrog
another metering technology to actually
more quickly get to the what what is
Promised by new technology which is
active load management and transactive
energy sure
um sorry thank you Mr
so
the term smart meter Gateway device is
defined in statute and requires uh
customer consent in order for the
utility to install the device and for
those members of the committee who have
been around a while will recall many
discussions and passionate discussions
on the part of some members of the
public around that and concerns with
with health effects of of meter
Communications so they are two different
things but the the question you're
asking is you know should
for load control be looking further out
and and I the answer to that is yes and
I think
um
what we're seeing and what we're
implementing is sort of a future where
there isn't a smart meter Gateway device
to do load control we have a pilot
program right now uh pilot demand
response program that on the residential
side it's a voluntary program that
allows us to at the customer's consent
control their Wi-Fi enabled thermostat
and it's a third party that that does
that there's no device that we're
installing at the home there's the Wi-Fi
thermostat that the customer installs
and then a third party does that control
at customer consent and so I think
that's
how things are evolving that there's not
a Communications device that is wired
into your house it is you know as they
say I guess less popular phase phrase
now but the internet of things where uh
there's Cloud management of devices
whether it's uh uh you know again a
water heater a furnace or potentially
another Appliance or in in the future uh
an electric vehicle
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um I believe it's safe to assume that
eversource and most utilities are not
adjusting time accounting inventory
system any idea what the inventory cost
would be to have these on stock in stock
and how much the inventory of volume
would need to be and would that cost be
passed to the rate payers
uh I I don't know the answers to most of
those questions so
um I I think as envisioned by the bill
that the and as uh was testified to the
individual customer requesting the smart
Gateway device would be responsible for
for the cost of that
what that would be I I you know we would
obviously have to do quite a bit of work
to to figure that out you know what
vendor what device
um and the like
representative munz asked a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
for coming in here I have a two-part
question
um the back the back office uh back room
systems that you spoke of that you know
control the meters and customer service
and billing
um are those consistent across your
areas of operation in other words is the
system you use in Massachusetts the same
as you use in New Hampshire
and if so
wouldn't the changes that you're you're
now making to respond to the the
um decision of the the regulator in
Massachusetts wouldn't that also benefit
you in New Hampshire and minimize the
cost to implement it here
so they are different systems across
each jurisdiction I believe in some
states even
across different areas of the state
there are different systems the company
I believe are long-term goal would be to
have a standardization across all of our
service territories and to answer the
second question certainly the work
that's being done in Massachusetts
at that future date could be leveraged
to to help make it a more efficient
conversion to a standardized system uh
in New Hampshire at a future date
foreign
Noel has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh I I take it from
your presentation that your opposition
is based on the amount of time that this
bill allows you to perform what you're
describing is is system analysis or
duties to be able to put this in place
if we expanded the time the bill allows
for this to be implemented uh say to six
months or maybe a year would that
remove your opposition or would that be
more acceptable yeah so our our
opposition to the bill really stems from
whether it's a smart Gateway device or a
smart Ami meter
um
the customer who is is requesting that
wants functionality from that device you
know I don't think they just want the
device for the sake of the device and
that is a much that is a significant and
complicated question that involves cost
um and what we're suggesting is that
there are studies underway for
components of that at the very least and
you know as I discussed sort of the
multi-year rollout in Massachusetts
um you know I there's a lot to consider
uh not just sort of placing the meter on
the side of a business or home uh
involved so it
I think there's there's more to consider
than than is here
follow up thank you Mr chair
does your work or your analysis work in
Massachusetts
help you expedite the rollout the
potential roll out of such devices here
yeah as as I uh responded to
representative munz I I think the work
that we are doing in Massachusetts while
you know it's not one for one New
Hampshire has has its own
um you know unique uh characteristics
that work will help uh you know we'll
have lessons learned what went right
what went wrong how can we do this
better uh faster more efficiently so so
that work you know I believe will help
inform our future work at some point in
New Hampshire
representative has a question thank you
chairman and thank you for taking my
question the Ami meters you mentioned
are those do those support time of use
thank you
uh Ami meters can support time of use
rates AMR meters can support time of use
rates as well
representative munz has another question
thank you Mr chair what just follow up
on
um what on the question from from
representative Noel
um and um I'll preface it by saying I'm
I'm acutely aware of what happens when
you assume
um but assuming that um
you know upgrading to these these smart
meters
is going to be it would be beneficial to
eversource as well as beneficial to the
um consumers is there anything that we
can do and to make this bill
more attractive to you to make it more
of a positive incentive to kind of move
the ball forward
um
I I think that's a fair question
I would like to have time to consider
what
policy objectives could be placed into
statute that would help facilitate sort
of a future conversion so be happy to to
get back to you with some thoughts on
that
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chair uh so I I just heard
you say that AMR and Ami meters can do
time of use uh
so
you have AMR meters if the goal is time
of use for charging EVS
do we even need to make the change
um it's so the Ami meter uh and and I
want to make sure I'm
accurately capturing this so
um
I might wanna
phone a friend and and get back to the
committee on this
um but but it's really the the
granularity of the information that the
meter allows for
um and the sophistication of the meter
so uh you know if we're talking about
sort of
on Peak off peak sort of you know to to
um
uh two types of rate or you know an
hourly rate which is often talked about
with transactive energy so it really
depends on the granularity of the
information but I I guess I would uh
asked to to check to make sure uh I'm
I'm accurately capturing that
follow up
so I would appreciate then if you could
make that
uh assessment and send that information
back to the committee yes
representative partial has a question
yes they can share it folks I think it's
very exciting I'll put out RFP for our
study and I hope it's a cost benefit
study as well looking at such things as
uh flattening the demand curve and
transactional energy
um now he said that in Massachusetts and
in Connecticut you're already moving
down further down the road of
incorporating
I'll call it smart technology upgrading
the grid
um if they manage to lower their Peak
that will result in lower demand for
those two states well New Hampshire
benefit from a lower demand from their
states through ISO
um
so just to be clear we received approval
in Massachusetts in November to move
forward with with the conversion
um
the meters in and of themselves don't
reduce Peak it's it's the programming uh
behind them
um and and
you know the incentives that that get
offered to customers
um and so certainly anything that any
state in the region does to reduce their
usage during times of Peak load benefits
all as you've heard from from the iso if
we you know the system is very much
designed from a capacity energy and
transmission standpoint to to meet the
peak you know hour of the peak day of
the peak month of the peak year and so
um if the the system is designed and the
costs are built in to to meet that Peak
then reducing
um reducing that benefits all
um now some companies have uh in in some
states have looked to try to reduce
their transmission charges which are
their share of charges during that that
Peak they would would have specific
customer benefits associated with that
that would not necessarily flow to to
all
thank you
follow up one more quasi yeah sort of a
follow-up
um will you be employing the least cost
integrated resource plan and is that
something is this a place where we where
perhaps it's appropriate to employ
employ that if it were functioning to
the top of its ability yeah uh
the transition to uh an Ami meter
um would be part of a lease cost
planning proceeding that would be a
significant uh investment with you know
lots of of costs and benefits to uh to
consider and that would be be a part of
the the utilities long-term planning
thank you so much
representative closure has a question
uh thank you chair thank you Mr Lakota
taking my question what I'm looking at
is this is an opt-in plan
is eversource now putting Gateway or
smart meters out on customers
that do not have an input on it do they
ask oh no uh we we do not so uh per
state statute
um we do not would not install a smart
Gateway device without customer consent
uh and as I said we don't have a program
um right now that that would require
that we do have a voluntary program
where customers can can enroll and
produce their their uh thermostat
through through Wi-Fi
okay
seeing no further questions from the
committee I want to thank you Mr locata
for being here
and I will call on the
last pink card that I have before me and
ask that Susan Durling from Hillsborough
come up front and give us your
perspective on this bill Ms darling
thank you
thank you for being here
press the button please
excellent good morning chairman those
and members of the committee my name is
Susan darling I live in Hillsboro and
I'm a member of the town's energy
Commission
and we have recently been looking into
uh Community power as a way to give our
residents more control over costs and
sustainable energy choices one of our
conversations about Community power
got into time of use
and um
that's one of the things that would
require Smart Meters the other choices
are fairly easy offering people rates
and sustainability levels
why would anyone want to use time of use
pricing
well one of the reasons might be that
the grid needs it
we all have heard that our electric grid
needs Improvement to manage future needs
and pricing that changes according to
the time of day can reduce strain on the
electrical grid by motivating people to
shifting their usage to off-peak hours
and this would also save money for
utilities because fuel prices will be
lower during those hours
I'm also the proud owner of a used
electric vehicle this year and I would
very much be interested in being able to
charge it during off-peak hours
time of use pricing also reduces the
need for expensive Peak power plants we
pay a lot of money to these power plants
to just sit there idly most of the time
and when we encourage people to shift
their uses to off-peak hours
we can reduce the need for these money
hungry plants the bow plant is costing
us ISO New England customers almost 20
million just this year just to sit there
most of the time and be ready
and
um
as an aside coal is a really tough
fuel to use for Peak it takes a long
time to warm up and get ready and work
well
time of use pricing can also help with
integrating renewable energy sources
into the grid since the sun isn't always
shining in the wind isn't always blowing
shifting uses to off-peak hours can
reduce the need from other sources that
are more expensive
Smart Meters can also release us from
bondage to one electric company
I'm sure some of us remember the time
when you had to use One telephone system
and to buy your equipment from one
company and when you want to call your
sister in the next town it was a toll
call none of us would like to go back to
that
we got our service from one company that
had complete control and electric meters
are now tied to the company we get our
service from in a similar way there is
no reason we need to continue that we
should be able to give consumers the
choice that smart meters would give
and I think it is in the interest of
eversource to drag this out and make it
as
um
a long implementation process as
possible because if that happened they
would be forced to be more competitive
and their rates might go down
getting a smart meter is a choice an
informed choice for the consumers of New
Hampshire we can choose to approve the
efficiency of our furnaces balancing
costs and benefits and consumers of
electricity should be able to make the
same choices if they want to buy a smart
meter because they figured out they're
going to save money they should be able
to do it
Smart Meters give consumers more freedom
to control use and costs Smart Meters
can reduce energy costs
result in a more sustainable power grid
and help manage energy demand they are a
technology we should definitely be
taking advantage of thank you
thank you Ms darling for
taking the trouble to come in and talk
to us today we appreciate getting your
perspective just for clarity is your
perspective because you wrote on your
pink card that you were representing
yourself is your perspective just your
own or is that the perspective of the
Hillsborough energy committee as well I
um decided on the spur of the moment
last night to come in today so I did not
discuss my testimony with the committee
so I don't feel comfortable saying I
represent them
great thanks for clarifying that
questions for Ms Durling representative
munz has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for coming in and um
want to try to leverage your expertise
as a member of a local energy committee
I must I'm assuming that
um
you you and your committee have
determined that the meters that are in
place in Hillsboro won't Supply
I won't um support time of use
rates we do not have information
currently on the meters that exist in
the community but from
um General
kind of community knowledge I don't
think most of the community has a smart
meter follow-up follow-up
do you know if you're if the rates in
your town or AMR or Ami
meters
do I know if our meters are AMR or Ami
right no I don't okay thank you
could you refresh our memory which
utility serves Hillsboro eversource
eversource okay thank you
seeing no more questions I want to thank
you for once again for coming in and
since I have no more pink cards on this
uh Bill HB 631fn I'll ask if there is
anybody else in the room who would like
to say something about this bill before
we conclude this public hearing
seeing none I'll ask representative
closure to give us a
a sense of what the blue sheet says
about this bill
uh thank you chair
hb631 blue sheet had one in support
another pose on line 12 inch support to
a pose thank you
thank you and with that we'll close the
public hearing on House Bill 631 FN and
we'll take a bio break until 10 o'clock
at which time we will hear House Bill
159. thank you very much
okay ladies and gentlemen time to get
back to work
I would like to open a public hearing on
House Bill 159 and call to the front of
the room the prime sponsor of the bill
representative Rebecca McWilliams
just to let every know everyone know I
have
a stack of pink cards
okay
I currently have 10 pink cards
of people who want to testify on this
bill so
we may be
well maybe 11. and that's including the
prime sponsor thank you Rebecca so we
may be limiting testimony to no more
than three minutes on this bill
however the prime sponsor will have
a good five minutes to introduce the
bill
thank you Rebecca
thank you chair Vos
um for the record my name is
representative Rebecca McWilliams I
represent South Concord it's a pleasure
to be here with you today
um by way of background I think we all
know that New Hampshire is facing a
energy crisis in terms of the
electricity rates that we have seen
spiking this winter
um
for a quality solid energy policy to
work in the state we need to have
consistent energy rates both for
businesses and for our own pocketbooks
as residential customers
and right now what we're seeing is crazy
volatility the inability to predict and
budget for uh doubling of electric rates
and so this is a concern I'm sure this
is a concern for everyone on this
committee and your constituents
therefore the intent of this bill House
Bill 159 is to come up with a way to
address spikes and volatility in the
electricity Arena
obviously this is a bill that's a first
pass and I believe that there's a lot of
opportunity for um
for for changing the way that we address
pricing and the way that the spikes
impact individuals and businesses here
in the state
so the goal here of course is to create
some kind of a gradual curve up and down
rather than crazy Spike and extreme
rates for our rate payers
just a little bit of background and
representative Corman would you mind
passing around those those amendments
that you picked up
um by way of background we know that
eversource currently goes out to bid
every six months to get new uh new
pricing information and figure out how
much electricity rates are going to be
that in a market where we are looking at
changes daily
um certainly monthly with the cost of
natural gas being impacted by
International markets and and the
conflict in Ukraine we know that that
type of bidding every six months really
leaves us with a very conservative cost
because it's hard to predict exactly
what's going to happen over the next
months and so therefore the idea here is
to come up with a mechanism and a way
that the pricing can be set on a shorter
basis and therefore more responsive to
Market rates and not locked in at a
six-month conservative with some fluff
built in price because of course the
businesses and consumers have to pay for
that conservative estimate so if you
look to the language on the bill as
introduced HP 159 what I did was I set a
five-year average of the retail rates
from ISO New England and I'm trying to
lock in rates in order to keep it more
along the line of a curve rather than
allowing a spike I've heard all kinds of
great feedback from different members of
the energy community in regards to how
this probably wouldn't work
there may be some concerns about
putting the potential risk on the
utilities which they're not really in a
position to to manage that level of risk
and I acknowledge that but also our
consumers are not really in a position
to manage this kind of risk and so we
have this Balancing Act between
consumers and the uh
the energy producers providers and
utilities so so really the goal here is
to come up with something as a committee
that could potentially address the
spikes and even out the curves so that
people are not stuck with crazy rates
when things like the conflict in Ukraine
happen having some kind of a buffer to
protect us
so as I said um representative Corman
did a great job passing out the
potential Amendment
um and I'd like to just address very
simply the language and the amendment is
enabling what's called laddering
laddering allows a utility to go out to
bid multiple times a year instead of
once every six months to get better
pricing this is enabled following the
Connecticut model ever source does this
in Connecticut right now and they have
developed having an individual role as
part of the Department of energy this
person is responsible for figuring out
what the appropriate timing is and how
how frequently utilities should be
getting their rates I think that in this
day and age in a modern time it's looked
it's time to look to modernizing both
time abuse rates and how frequently
utilities go out to bid instead of
locking in a six-month buffer and so as
I said this is really meant this Bill
House Bill 159 is really meant to be a
solution right now to the the energy
crisis that we are facing as a state
coming up with Innovative and Creative
Solutions to address the pain that all
of our constituents businesses and
consumers are feeling right now so I'm
happy to take questions on this and I'm
certainly happy to amend or do a
subcommittee on this bill I think that
this is a pressing issue and it's
something that we as a committee can
make a difference on thank you
thank you representative McWilliams for
introducing House Bill 159 you are
uniquely positioned as someone who has
legal training
to answer the question of whether the
bill as introduced would be
constitutional constitutional or not do
you have an opinion about that I think
there's a constitutional question Mr
chair okay great thank you
any additional questions for
representative McWilliams seeing none
I'd like to move on because we have a
lot of pink cards to get through in the
next hour or so so I'll call forward now
Mr Griffin Roberge from the Department
of energy to give us the Department's
perspective on this proposed legislation
foreign
thank you Mr chairman uh members of the
committee for the record Griffin Roberts
from the New Hampshire Department of
energy
the department is opposed to House Bill
159 as introduced um I will thank you
um I will note um I did have a com a
short conversation with representative
McWilliams last night to understand the
intent of her language which was
reiterated in her public testimony and
were certainly respectful of that um I
haven't had a chance to digest Amendment
0-557h so my comments will just be
focused on the bill as introduced if I
may interrupt you briefly we are not
allowed to consider amendments in public
hearings so just confine your remarks to
the bill as introduced that's my
attention yep I can do that
um so to open up to provide context New
Hampshire's electric distribution
utilities as part of restructuring under
RSA 374f do not own generating assets or
the resources to produce electric power
for the the energy sold to cons to
customers through default service
whichever Source unitel Liberty those
unit those utilities competitively
solicit prices from generators for
electric power on the wholesale Market
through a competitive solicitation
that's typically done every six months
um the prices reflect wholesale market
conditions and Electric utilities do not
make any profit from the sale of that
default service power is direct
pass-through to Consumers the New
Hampshire Public Utilities Commission
then conducts an adjudicative proceeding
to determine the utilities electric
rates this adjudication ensures that the
costs recovered by the utilities are
prudently incurred and are just fair and
reasonable as we mentioned on earlier
bills this year these terms prudently
incurred and just fair and reasonable
are important as they have significant
legal implications built upon many years
of legal precedent what's important to
note is that the cost for default Energy
service again the cost of the power
procured by these utilities are directly
passed through to New Hampshire's
electric consumers they don't make any
rate of return on these power costs but
they make utilities make a rate of
return on the resources needed to
distribute and transmit that power to
customers
circling back to the bill the bill seeks
to amend RSA 374 f
colon 3 which outlines a variety of
restructuring policy principles when New
Hampshire restructured its utilities
again this section of statue is meant to
offer some legislative guiding policy
principles rather than any type of
mandatory requirement at least in this
specific language so lines three to five
change the term should to shall
effectively requiring that default
service utilities shall be designed to
provide a safety net and to assure
universal access in system Integrity
while obviously default service
companies are legally required to
provide electric service to their
customers this change does raise some
questions rather than being should it's
a shell now so it's mandatory so does
that mean that potentially do default
service utilities provide service even
in the event of a customer who's not
paying their bill
similar concerns are on lines four to
five if default service providers have
failed default service solicitations are
they still getting competitive electric
prices if not those those providers
could potentially be violating the state
statute again the conversion of of the
of the phrase shall to should reduce his
flexibility and then in an area of
Statute that has policy principles and
makes the statute more of a requirement
and therefore more difficult to
implement
um circling to the main thrust of the
bill on lines 5 to 11.
um the bill indicates that the cost of
procured power shall be recovered from
retail rate pairs based upon a rate
calculated by using the five-year
average of the retail rates for the New
England region as posted by ISO New
England the language then spells out how
the average how the average is
recalculated and then how uh the rates
are the but how the rates are charged to
rate payers and they cannot exceed a
rolling five-year rate we want to note
several observations with the bill first
ISO New England does not post retail
default Service rates it does calculate
and post the locational market market
prices at various nodes throughout New
England default service prices are
posted in the tariffs of the new New
England utilities that operate
throughout the region though they do not
all use the same language and it's not
always clear what is intended in those
other states utilities tariff rates
second this language overlooks the
differences between default power and
default service default Service rates
are are quoted by electric suppliers and
they include more than just the bare
cost of electricity such as risk
premiums or RPS compliance costs those
are built into default Service rates as
I said there are other costs that are
not separated out during the bidding
process for default service power in
default service solicitations and then
finally
while we understand the department now
understands the intent is to lessen
energy costs for ratepayers and to
introduce some laddering effect or
having utilities sign contracts or
Powers uh signing contracts for power at
different rates or at varying terms to
mitigate Market volatility
um this change could be legally
problematic the language outlines how
the price of electricity is set to be
charged to retail customers devoid of
actual Market costs for example if the
price of electricity is actually higher
than the five-year average that's posted
in the bill utilities can only collect
up to the five-year average uh price in
such a Circumstance the bill would
likely be an unconstitutional taking
under the Fifth Amendment
additionally it's not clear how any
overage would be paid devoid of any
constitutional claim
um doe believes utilities would be on
the hook for that overage essentially
creating some type of deferred liability
for them and I think the prime sponsor
indicated that that that's likely an
issue with this bill and would maybe
require some further vetting conversely
what if the price of electricity is less
than the five-year average do rate
payers may be locked into paying higher
electric rates that do not reflect
Market realities so do you kill
utilities keep the money to pay down any
type of deferred liability do utilities
return any excess funds to rate payers
if there is a return to rate payers how
is that process conducted these are all
uh large questions with the bill as
introduced and I understand from the
prom sponsors testimony that this is
kind of a first a first step into a
larger conversation the department would
certainly be willing to take part in
that conversation if the bill is
retained or goes to a subcommittee the
only other thing I'd want to reference
is that by way of background the puc
currently has an open investigatory
docket that's IR 22-053
that is examining all the pertinent
aspects of New Hampshire's default
service procurement that that docket
opened in September 2022 and it may lead
to further discussions as to how default
service procurement may be improved in
the future and with that that concludes
my testimony and happy to answer any
questions
okay thank you
well over six minutes uh representative
Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Roberts good to see you as always good
to see you uh you referred to the bill
as written as
doing laddering
um I but it's really about a five-year
rolling average is there are you saying
that that's really the same as laddering
or is there some sort of difference
thank you for the question I I think I'd
kind of parcel a bit and say it it looks
and I think the Department's perspective
it looks like a type of laddering it's
not exactly laddering in the straight up
sense that you'd expect
um you know I think uh the LA the
traditional laddering framework
um is meant to have utilities go out for
power at varying times layer their
contracts in a way so that people aren't
hit with a flat cost up front as the
prime sponsor indicated prevent those
sudden spikes and everything like that
but I would just contend that in a
traditional laddering model while there
may be benefits to a lettering approach
of say energy costs go higher there is a
there is a negative impact if costs go
lower so if the market you know is
selling power at a very low price but
your laddering mechanism is still still
selling power to your customers at a
higher price you're separated from
Market realities and consumers could be
paying more than what the market is
actually offering if that makes sense
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh we heard uh earlier in
the year about how New England Co-op
does its pricing would their methodology
of how they're doing their pricing meet
the intent of what this bill is trying
to do and would that be an easier
process to get done thank you for the
question so potentially it could I don't
want to speak too much for the co-op and
I didn't speak too much in depth with
our regulatory staff about New Hampshire
Electric co-ops method way of doing it
but I know that's been something that's
been discussed
um I imagine any type of approach that
they currently have in place would
likely be an Avenue that is discussed in
the IR docket that I referenced at the
puc
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman and just to follow
up on representative Thomas's question
there
um would this bill if passed eliminate
the puc standing order that that the
utilities could only go to market once
every six months it thank you for the
question it it it it certainly could
um as I'm sure this committee is aware
um you know the puc issued an order
um dealing with Energy Efficiency
programs and the legislature came in and
passed House Bill 549 to kind of correct
that that order so it is likely that the
passage of the bill in its current form
um would likely uh override some of the
puc's abilities to
uh map out default service procurements
representative Reynolds hopefully has a
question rather than a statement thank
you Mr chairman
um
yes Mr aburst is the depart is the
department supportive in concept of the
idea that
New Hampshire residents and businesses
need to be
better
insulated from the short-term ups and
downs of the market and would benefit
from more stability
in the way
utilities
set their rates
sure thank you for the question yes so
you know as we emphasize in um our
state's 10-year State energy strategy
the Departments does have a very keen
goal of keeping an eye on electric rates
through the lens of the ratepayer the
department is an active participant in
the IR docket that I that I previously
mentioned providing feedback on various
um different proposals or ideas about
um about default service procurement for
example there have been some discussions
about uh in the docket about a
descending clock auction for default
service procurement the department at
least in that is not recommending that
Approach at this time just because we
want to internally review that approach
and I think in that IR docket there's
some intention about having a
presentation about that type of
procurement option so again I think a
lot of these questions are kind of being
hashed out in the IR docket that's being
discussed thank you
representative munz has a quick question
be very quick and probably the simplest
question you're going to get today what
was that IR what was that docket number
again thank you for the question that is
the easiest question I hope to get today
um that is ir22
-053 and uh I did send a link to that
late last night to representative
McWilliams I'm happy to share a link to
that uh docket with members of the
committee here as well
wonderful thank you we appreciate the uh
Department being here to follow up
follow-up go ahead
I I don't want to let them off the hook
that easy
um
just a quick a quick follow-up I I
understand that there may be some
question as to whether the puc actually
has the authority through this docket to
overrule
what the current practice is can you
comment on that yeah sure thank you for
the question so I'm going to ask you not
to answer that question it's not really
relevant to the bill and it's an
interesting topic but we'll let's save
that for another day okay okay all right
well thank you
we appreciate the Department's
perspective and now would like to hear
the perspective of eversource on this
legislation as introduced
foreign
again Michael Licata representing
eversource energy I'll be brief I think
I put three minutes on my card I think I
can do it in less uh
don't want to be repetitive with the
testimony of the Department of energy
but essentially we agree with uh their
read of the legislation as introduced we
would be opposed and it is very much the
same concerns that we expressed on HB
633 which the committee voted 20-0 to
itl again for the reason that it
separates the rate that the utility is
allowed to charge from the cost the
utility incurs to provide service
um that said uh very much appreciate the
intent of the bill sponsor and her uh
testimony that uh you know she wants to
to address this issue
um and in fact I think the word she used
were addressed spikes and volatility
um there are a number of different ways
as was previously discussed that the
utility could procure default Service uh
right now this six month load following
rfps
um they are designed to to essentially
mirror Market at those exact moments in
time and the customers are sort of have
a maximum Market exposure and if there
is volatility in the market by design
that is what uh the customers are seeing
certainly we use the the example of the
rate set back in in August of last year
where the default service rate doubled
and that was what the market was doing
at the time and that's what customers
paid and so
um we certainly have thoughts and and
ideas if the goal the policy goal is to
provide price stability and reduce
Market volatility then again there's a
very different way we could go about
doing this and we would welcome the
opportunity to work with the bill
sponsor the committee and other
stakeholders on language to address that
I have not seen the the amendment so I
certainly can't speak to that and with
that happy to answer any questions that
the committee may have
thank you Mr locata
I hope those assembled will follow Mr
lakota's lead by staying well within the
time limit that he requested two minutes
five seconds well done
any questions for Mr locata
we don't accept questions from the
audience for people who are testifying
if you want a member of the committee to
ask a question you could consult with
someone and they could ask the question
on your behalf
uh all right
seeing no questions for Mr locata we'll
move along
and I'll next ask Mr Michael Krauss
newly joined to the office of the
consumer Advocate to provide his
perspective on this proposed legislation
Mr Krause welcome thank you
good morning as a matter a brief
introduction since this is my first time
testifying my name is Michael Krauss I'm
the new staff attorney at the office of
the consumer Advocate I graduated from
Vermont law school I have four brief
points to address and I do not wish to
reiterate too many points from
eversource or the department of energy
but first and foremost the OCA testifies
in support of this bill the OCA shares
representative mcwilliam's concern about
the soaring cost of default Energy
service and the need to re-examine how
default Energy Services procured however
with the Bill's original approach
discussing this five-year average is
flawed because it would create
unrecoverable stranded costs or it could
lead to deferred costs that are unfair
to Future customers
third and generally speaking these
questions tend to involve policy choices
surrounding the nature of default Energy
Service procurement and therefore the
ocas on the fence as a scene in the IR
docket 22-053 mentioned earlier about
who might be the best source of that
option whether it be the general court
depending on how prescriptive it is or
even discussing with the Department of
energy as some form of alternative
service procurement manager but
ultimately the OCA test device and
supported this bill and shares the
concerns of Representative Nick Williams
in the interest of time we're open to
any questions asked thank you
thank you uh questions for Mr Krause
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for coming in
um I'm sorry I I didn't catch
um your you made some comments related
to the um
the the open docket and could you just
repeat those I didn't hear them yes I'm
happy to repeat are you able to hear me
clearly
great uh generally speaking the issues
surrounding default Energy Service rates
and their procurement involves policy
questions and the OCA was mentioning
that in IR docket
22-053 that's the department of energy
brought up that's what the puc is
currently exploring is some of those
Alternatives and how that can actually
be addressed and just generally speaking
the OCA is expressing that those policy
choices might be more appropriate before
the general court or working out an
arrangement with the Department of
energy or other interested parties on
those Solutions in that docket
so you know further questions I want to
thank you for being here and say hello
to Don cries for us when you get back to
the office thank you chairman
next up I'll call on
van Gaudet from rumney
good morning and welcome to sdne Good
morning hi thank you for having me my
name is Von Gaudet and I am fond Cadet
I'm from Romania Hampshire I'm a member
of the public I just wanted to share
that many people are are struggling and
going through hardship to pay on their
energy bills and this is the highest
single rate increase in New Hampshire
history and another key point is the
best way to lower energy demand bills is
to not need it and to move forward to
renewable energy sources that will help
people save money such as energy saving
Investments such as offshore wind
potential to look into in solar energy
and these resources are boundless in in
their green resources that will help
people and help our climate and our
environment for the future our future
generations and I think that you all
have the power to take these steps to
help us move forward and protect our
protect our climate and our help our
people in New Hampshire so I hope you
please support
hpe159 and thank you so much for your
time
any questions
for MS gaudette
seeing none I want to thank you for
being here long drive appreciate you
coming down next we'll call on Susan
darling who we heard from in the last
hour
she's from Hillsboro and she's here
representing herself
welcome back
thank you
just have a couple of brief comments
that
um
Ms Gaudet address most of my issues
right now just from a citizen Observer
of the puc it seems to me that most of
the power at setting rates is on the
side of the utilities
and I would just like to see
our Representatives putting a thumb on
the scale on the side of the consumers
and help us with some guard rails so
that we're not we got to plan our
budgets too and buy groceries and buy
medications and I'd just like to see
some guard rails set and I do support
this Bill thank you
thank you questions for Ms darling
seeing none I want to thank you for
taking the time to come talk to us today
next I'll call on
Ms Kaylee Coates of Hooksett New
Hampshire here representing herself
welcome
good morning my name is Kaylee Coates I
am a resident of Hooksett I'm here today
and to express my support for
hb159 it's imperative to book guard
rails on the energy procurement process
at the New Hampshire Public Utilities
Commission the puc is supposed to
protect the ratepayers against unjust
price hikes however electricity rates
have recently doubled the largest
increase in New Hampshire history
such unchecked increases makes it near
impossible for younger Generations like
myself to own homes and keep up with
utilities
I would like to settle down in the place
where I grew up a state that I love but
the Steep increases in the cost of
living paired with plateauing wages
means I soon might have to look
elsewhere for places to live
these ever increasing bills are common
topic discussed between my friends and
peers I would hate to see a mass
migration away from the state
being hit with an electric bill that has
doubled what I budgeted for means having
to sacrifice other necessities in my
life
furthermore I believe could I interrupt
you for a second yes
[Music]
well it's interesting to hear the
perspective you're providing it doesn't
really talk about the substance of the
bill do you have any actual substance
substantive comments on the use of a
five-year running average and other
specifics related to the bill
sure
um I believe that we need to be
readjusting the price increases more
often than every six months
clearly this isn't working if we're
having such steep increases from six
months to six months
okay thank you appreciate you being here
to give us your perspective any
questions
seeing none oh thank you and call on
next miss Catherine corkery representing
the New Hampshire Sierra Club for her
perspective on this legislation thank
you
[Music]
um
thank you
and Miss corkery I'll remind you that
we're interested in hearing about the
specifics of the bill
specifically the rolling five-year
average
proposal that's in the bill
my comments are geared towards the bill
good thank you
um I
my name is Catherine corkery and I
represent New Hampshire Sierra Club we
have over 17
000 members and supporters in New
Hampshire and our motto is to enjoy
explore and protect the Earth
today I'm honored to present to the
committee that this that the chapter
supports
the bill hb159
um as noted earlier the puc commission
supports the just fair and reasonable
standard for rates
and the statute says the default
Services which are designed to minimize
customer risk
that's what the statute says
and I think
um we've seen these rates this process
is broken it's neither just or
reasonable
and the evidence is the doubling of
people's electricity bills
um I represent people in New Hampshire
who've had to face with these doubling
rates and I understand that it's
supposed to be a pass-through cost
meaning that the utilities charge what
they pay
um I'm gonna have to stop you there
remember this bill doesn't talk about
the doubling of rates it doesn't talk
about just and reasonable so please
confine your comments to the bill itself
it's it's in that statute it's pertains
to that statute
and
um I I would I do think my comments
relate to the bill
what is uh what we see is that the rate
hike makes it clear that the fossil fuel
Market is unpredictable and Beyond the
control of the puc and the state of New
Hampshire
and what's puzzling is that New
Hampshire rates
are higher than the rate in other states
and even within the state they're not
uniform
why what why why why is that and we know
that the co-op uses a different model
but what about what about the other
states why why is it that ever sources
rates are so different in every other
state
why is it that unitels is different in
every other state
and
what are they doing that we're not doing
is my question and this bill is to
answer that question 15 seconds please
I would like to take longer because I
have and I will be sending these letters
through the
um the portal the state the portal for
comments I have collected almost 100
letters of your constituents
and the pain that they are feeling with
this rate hike
and in particular
this idea
that we should control what we can and I
would like longer time sir
um if if I may
and 30 seconds I'll give you 30 seconds
thank you I I would like longer but uh
controlling what we can by putting the
guard rails on procurement and focusing
away from
the fossil fuel
sources by investing longer to build
resiliency and lower the demand at the
source with the rate payers
repairs want to spend less on their
energy bills and there are ways okay
I've given you additional time we need
to move on and then quickly I just want
to share some of the comments sir
um one is from Westchester field we are
on a fixed income
the energy rate seems Criminal
this is these are people regular people
and I will be submitting these uh I also
submitted to the committee a uh
um
a handout from our friends at Acadia
Center we got it thank you great and and
I assure you that the comments that you
just shared with us are comments that we
have heard from our constituents many
many times we're well aware of the pain
and suffering that people are
experiencing from high electricity rates
and I encourage this community thank you
for your testimony to take it we'd like
to move on because we have several other
people who would like to testify here
this afternoon
next I'll call on Karen Irwin from
Hopkinton to give us her perspective
and Miss Aaron I would urge you to
refrain from talking about
how these electricity rates affect you
personally we want to hear if you have
any unique information to provide about
the substance of the bill namely the
rolling five-year average averaging of
electricity cost
and please confine your comments to two
minutes please
okay my name is Karen Irwin I'm
representing myself and I'm from
Hopkinton New Hampshire
um I want to reiterate some of the
comments that have come in here from the
prime sponsor who says this is a work in
process this is a project something that
needs to happen for the good of our
Statewide constituencies and customers
I um The Five-Year average might not be
the best basis but there's got to have
something we have to have some changes
six months isn't working those Peaks and
valleys for people aren't working and so
I one thing that came to mind is I
listened to all the testimony that came
through from the department and others
is that you know I look at what we do uh
to buy our oil everybody goes under a
contract well not everybody everybody
can afford it goes under a contract we
have a year contract and then we have
the downside protection that we can do
why can't we do I don't know this
process but why can't we do something
that at least goes out a year so people
know what they're what they're going to
be paying for these rates and make it
more of a public process now this is
supposed to be a public process in this
legislation today but I am really hoping
because there's a lot of work to to be
done and it shouldn't just be itl'd that
this bill
you know you create a subcommittee and
allow more open testimony and more
thoughts and ideas to go into this
process
um 30 seconds it is it is credibility
that you listen to the public on this
and I know you don't want to reiterate
you know and I am talking a little bit
on my letter but I I am um about my
personal situation but um I'm going to
hand that out and but I had testimony
subsequent to that and I think it's it's
valuable that we create a subcommittee
so I I encourage you to support this
bill in some way work out the
Constitutional issues but put it into
subcommittee at least please
okay thank you Miss Irwin appreciate it
moving along we'll Now call on Mr art
Cunningham also from Hopkinton who also
apparently represents the Sierra Club
Mr Cunningham two minutes please members
of the committee
uh yeah my name is Art Cunningham uh
I live in Hopkinton my office is in
Hopkinton I'm an attorney
uh and Kathy Corky of the Sierra Club
asked me to come in and testify on this
bill
my background with the Sierra Club
my background was Sierra Club over the
history as uh but particularly in
connection with the eversource
uh I worked on the scrubber uh
because we believed the scrubber
violated the Clean Air Act on the new
source review standards
I've worked on Knox for the Sierra Club
because Knox is a problem in the state
because we have difficulties with ozone
I've made appearance before the air
Resources Council and the puc on behalf
of Sierra Club and I've worked on
eversources title V
IA
the idea of this bill
is to provide a cap
on these rate spikes let me put it this
way
they go out every six months
on an arbitrary date it's like playing
Russian roulette
whatever the price is in the wholesale
Market on that date is what the rate
payers get stuck with
that is no way
just and reasonable
it's no way to treat rate payers and
it's no way for
utilities are to serve the public
to act now I listened to the Oregon 30
seconds please
your honor your honor Mr chairman I've
spent so many years in court sorry
but I have some substantive comments to
make about my listening to the Oregon
testimony
and one of the questions was that never
got answered by the utility by
d-e-o-d-o-e or the OCA was what's the
source what was the source of this going
out twice a year
why why is that standing as the rule on
how wholesale electricity is purchased
now what I did and Kathy handed it out
the source of that rule is found in
order number Public Utilities Commission
order number 26092
which was issued in an eversource case
on December 29 2017.
now it's very very important for this
committee to understand the source of
this rule
so what I did each each member of the
committee now has a copy
of this order and what I asked Kathy to
do is to redline
substance substantive parts of the order
if you look in your order
like I say I think it's critically
important for this committee to
understand the basis
of this what I consider to be absolutely
arbitrary
procurement process
can you explain quickly why
understanding this is critical to this
because I heard like Mr chairman I heard
multiple questions from this committee
during the Oregon Bill what is the
source
why is it or why are the utilities
buying power twice a year on the
wholesale Market on arbitrary days what
is the legal source
of that practice and I heard misleading
answers
I heard the eversource lobbyists say
while it's in the statute let me assure
you Mr chairman members of the committee
it's not in the statute the source of
that
purchasing
Authority is found in this order
okay we get that so thank you we
appreciate you giving us that
information and if you look through the
if if you look through for example on
page 15
if you want to have an understanding of
what the statute says
with regard to energy purchase look at
page 15.
that it says and you can look read it
for yourself but it says
this is RSA 374 F3 4 little C
the the important part here is it
includes access to service with an
option of stable and predictable rates
for customers recovery of the cost
competitively procured power through
Energy Service rates
that's what the statute says the statute
does not
describe the procurement process this
order does
another important part of this order
is found on
you're up over five minutes now
Mr chair I I would like to finish please
do and do it as quickly as you can
with due respect
this committee needs to know
the source of this Authority and they
also need to know how it can be fixed
and
first of all this order specifically
provides
and you'll find that marked in red that
any party
including eversource the OCA a member of
the public
any party can reapply to the Public
Utilities Commission to fix this order
in other words
it can be done not by Statute it can be
done simply by order but the problem
here is nobody seems to want to do it
so I'm asking the legislature
to put in this guard rail
the force the utilities
to go back and figure out a better
procurement method
and I've got one more suggestion for you
Mr chairman members of the committee as
an amendment a proposed amendment
let's do this let's not
let's not impose
that's put put a lot put the
cap in place
but put in a put in a revised Statute by
way of amendment
that ever Source or Unitil or Liberty
are free to go out
into the wholesale market and buy
electricity
whenever the Price Is Right let them
have that discretion let them have the
authority and let them have the
responsibility to responsibly buy
electricity
and if and if the purchase of that
electricity which is passed through the
costs are passed through if
the price of that electricity is less
than
the the rolling five-year average that's
in here
give the consumers that rate in other
words if it's less
give them that rate
um in other words built into this
statute this statute could use some work
but build into that statute if they
can buy electricity by smart purchasing
let the consumer have the benefit of
that lower rate and I suggest that as an
amendment this to this bill
let me address one more point
aerosource and the DOE
the lobbyists all come in all we've got
constitutional problems here
well think about it if this if the cap
is based on retail rates of an average
of retail rates
if a cap is based on an average of
retail rates in the region
what's wrong with the utilities in this
state why can't they meet the average
that that argument is just wrong the
other thing I would say about those
Market arguments that somehow this is an
infringement on their constitutional
rights or it'll create stranded costs
and whatever and whatever what I would
say to this committee
if they make such a claim then the puc
has the obligation to do a thorough
going audit
of why they make that argument in other
words this is not Mr chairman members of
committee kid games
I don't know why you would sit here and
listen to these blanket statements to
all this will put us into bankruptcy or
this is improper take it that is a wrong
orbit keep in mind let me repeat this
average is a of retail rates
so everybody else in the region is doing
it why can't they and if they make that
claim oh
this is unconstitutional or this is the
taking let the puc examine their books
and Records
so thank you very much for allowing a
bit of extra time but this is a serious
matter that needs serious study by this
committee and by the full legislature
thank you Mr chairman
your refusal to honor the time limits
that we've requested for the committee
hasn't done your cause
any good
I'm sorry sir thank you for being here I
appreciate it
we'll move on now and I'll call on
and I apologize if I mispronounce the
name
Elizabeth
bialoski
I hope I got that right
and please two minutes and please
confine your comments to the subject of
the bill
thank you chair and representatives
you're close it's biolovsky
so my name is Elizabeth bialoski and I'm
a lobbyist for 350 New Hampshire I also
have a master's degree from University
of Denver in Social Work concentrating
in energy and environmental policy
I strongly support
um hp159 and I believe it is necessary
for economic and energy stability in New
Hampshire the utility rate increases
over the past year have been
unprecedented and a huge financial
burden on many New Hampshire residents
and families I do believe personal
testimony for that is important and
can't be minimized no matter how often
or frequent it's being brought up
calculating rates based on a five-year
average with both stabilized pricing for
residents as well as create transparency
from utility companies
for example eversource reported 1.4
billion dollars in profit for 2022 which
is 184 million dollar increase from
2021. there's definitely a problem right
now with market and supply and I
acknowledge that but there's also a
discrepancy between price and utility
company profits right now as well that
is relevant to why this bill is
important
utility companies should not be able to
Skyrocket prices on a whim and it's
concerning how many of these companies
are hitting record profits while our
residents can't afford to keep heat on
in the winter consequently I support
this bill and any amendments that take
um market price into acknowledgments as
well as the fact that every other region
in New England has been able to adopt
similar policies to this I'll also take
questions if anyone has any
thank you for keeping in your time limit
and well spoken I we all appreciate that
do we have any questions
seeing none
um I'm gonna you're excused thank you
very much thank you for your time yes
thank you uh I'd like just just to make
one statement before we move on just a a
very short statement because some of you
haven't been here all year or uh and we
receive a lot of testimonies and
information I don't want anyone out
there to think that this committee all
of us here do does not understand what's
going on with the rate hikes the uh or
how they're determined or that we or
that we are just listening to only one
side we listen
to almost every Bill involves some sort
of rate hike
in information
we absolutely hear what the public is
saying I have people in my own
constituents who I have visited that are
almost living in squalor because of
these high rates we get it uh we there
are systems there's bureaucracies we are
trying to find a good way I personally
feel this bill is a a nice attempt to
address it I think there's some
obstacles in there but you know we're
we're going to work our way through some
of them whichever Bill works I just want
the public to understand that and I
appreciate your concern we understand
everything here thank you for that for
indulging me on that and I will call
you know that's right we and we were
well aware of the puc order I don't know
uh where someone may have gotten the
idea that we that that we didn't know
that that order existed but it was not
in statute we knew about the puc order
and that's an issue that could be worked
given some time but we will uh we are
definitely looking at those things I
think I made a comment earlier today
about one utilities your method seems to
be working a little better than
something else that's in shoe that we
can bring up uh I'd like to move on and
go to the next uh speaker which is Tom
Warrior
excuse me I didn't pronounce your name
right
for you that's right
who's representing himself
thanks very much good morning everyone
maybe I should be speaking into this but
in the interest of time brevity I'm
going to adhere to that policy it's been
repeated uh but I just wanted to
um
I had a question for somebody in the
back here that spoke earlier
but the recurring theme just seems to be
without doubt that this six-month you
know going out to uh you know by
eversource and maybe it's other
utilities too including Liberty where
I'm from I'm from Salem New Hampshire
um it needs to be more frequent I bet
the technology is there I bet eversource
adds that technology as well
um so that's a recurring thing
I don't know I did some you know
statistics I'm big on that and I learned
that uh New Hampshire was the second uh
most expensive in the country for
electric utility rates behind Hawaii
which you might understand why they may
be
but my question is do you have a source
rep spoke earlier and he was mentioning
that there are various methods that they
can use to look into to level the rate
volatility what if he has any examples
of that and what they might be working
on
I think he's behind nope I I don't know
who that person was well
there he is
how you doing
is this something that eversource would
like to address or uh leave for later or
he's uh you know he's he's taking up
your time so whatever he wants to answer
go ahead yeah I'll yield okay
uh again Michael Licata ever Source
energy
um
so I I think the question was in
reference to what are other ways that
the utility could procure default
Service uh and has was mentioned
previously today
um one could go out for more frequent
solicitations for smaller amount of load
that's often called laddering as was
referenced by
one of the testifiers that is what we do
in um Massachusetts and Connecticut and
I would just point out as I did in my
previous testimony
uh on HB 633 when I did in fact cite the
order uh required by the commission
um that that was our original proposal
uh coming out of divestiture in New
Hampshire uh and the commission uh did
not want to go in that direction they
wanted to tie the rates to the market uh
so that customers would see market price
signals so that's certainly something we
could do there's also different varying
lengths of time for the procurements
right now again per puc order which is
supported by New Hampshire statute
the company goes out every six months in
Maine they go out every year for yearly
setting again that could be a way to to
stabilize prices instead of six month
solicitations one year solicitation so
there's a number of different levers one
could could use and as I test Justified
to earlier were happy to engage in those
conversations with stakeholders the bill
sponsor the committee
to adopt public policy to provide more
stability versus
Market exposure
thank you uh for uh keeping with the
time one one quick
uh confirmation or something uh a
utility such as eversource you you
cannot just arbitrarily go out and
change your method of uh pricing or
change your method of of uh how you're
supplying electricity uh without
guidance from the state is that a
correct statement that that is correct
uh the current process is authorized by
puc order again supported by New
Hampshire statute if we were to change
that process we would have to make a
filing with the Public Utilities
Commission as previously mentioned
there's an ongoing investigation looking
at the manner at the Public Utilities
Commission looking at the manner by
which all the utilities procure uh Power
but it would be an adjudicative
proceeding and ultimately if you see
order that would direct us to make a
change
thank you
um I really Mr Lakota was not really the
testifier uh I'd like to move on to our
last
speaker first if you have questions then
we can we can deal with them
and I will call our last speaker Mr
Dominic Osmond
oh well okay thank you for keeping
within your time Dominic
uh with that said is there a question
from the committee that we can answer
while we're here
representative one you have a short
question well my question is for Mr
locata if he's allowed to come back go
ahead
giving you your exercise today
thank you very much thanks for your your
uh your flexibility here
um so uh the fact that you're doing the
fact that you're doing laddering in
Massachusetts and Connecticut that would
suggest to me that you've got the the
processes the analytical tools
Etc in place to do that would that
assuming that either the puc or the
legislature allowed you to do that in MA
in New Hampshire would that would it be
a fairly s seamless
um that's well would it be would it be
easier easy for you to make that
transition to that type of a model yeah
the the
um
the the concept of an execution of
lottery in and of itself is is not
difficult or technically complex and we
can certainly
accommodate that it's you know obviously
each state does it a little bit
differently Connecticut does a little
bit differently than Massachusetts
presumably of New Hampshire went in that
direction it might be a little bit
different than those two states but we
could certainly accommodate that
um I I would just point out and I know
it's been said so laddering in and of
itself does not reduce cost laddering
provides
um more stability in pricing and I know
the it was referenced our rates in other
jurisdictions I would just point out
that those are currently higher than our
rate in New Hampshire today even with
the lattering so we're all procuring
from the same Market it's just how much
are you procuring at what point in time
and for what duration and so
um you know the as Mr Rober spoke you
know there are real challenges that are
driving costs in the market and it is by
and large tied to the cost of natural
gas which is a global commodity and so
different procurement strategies as
representative McWilliams said can have
different outcomes of trying to provide
some level of stability but ultimately
we're all buying from the same market
and market prices are what they are
okay thank you good okay with that said
no other for no further questions
and seeing none other speakers available
I will declare this public hearing
closed
Grant going to ask the um
everyone is free to leave for lunch I'm
going to ask the Republicans here to
stay here for a caucus please
oh I'm sorry the blue sheet first
and thank you Vice chair
house bill159 the blue sheet seven in
support one oppose
online
53 support three opposed thank you
thank you
all right I did forget to announce that
uh we're taking a lunch break and we
will be back here at 1pm for some
executive sessions on several bills
thank you
Christy
the executive sessions will start as
soon as all members are here and in
their seats
so good afternoon everybody
this is the science technology and
energy committee and we will be
conducting exec sessions or several
bills over the next uh
hour or two or however long it takes
we'll be doing House Bill 233 relative
to useful thermal energy under the
renewable portfolio standard
we'll be doing House Bill 257 relative
to telephone carrier of Last Resort
obligations
we'll be doing House Bill 251 relative
to the cost of compliance with
disclosure of electric renewable
portfolio standards
we'll be doing House Bill 263 requiring
notification
to Renewable Energy customer generators
of issues related to renewable energy
credits
House Bill 281 relative to least cost
integrated resource plans of utilities
House Bill 443 establishing a commission
to study the withdrawal of New Hampshire
from ISO New England bless you
House Bill 372 establishing a commission
to study the short and long-term impacts
of pending National and Regional carbon
pricing mechanisms on New Hampshire
citizens businesses
institutions and environment
and Hospital 605 relative to solar
generation under the renewable portfolio
standards
we will also resume the exact session on
Two Bills recessed
recently I don't remember exactly when
we recessed them but I'm talking about
House Bill 208
and house bill 298.
before we get to that I want to welcome
Joan Hamlet back to the committee who's
sitting in today for representative
McGee
welcome Andrew roszullo who's sitting in
today for representative Michael
Harrington
and welcome back Carol Brown who's
sitting in once again for John lewicki
and then a huge welcome back to
representative Jackie creation who's
back after being out for a couple three
weeks with uh
some broken ankle issues so welcome back
Jackie
so with that I'd now like to recognize
representative McWilliams
this is Hospital 233 just confirming Mr
chair
you have a motion I'm sorry is this
house bill 233 I'm just confirming Mr
chair
um I'd like to I'd like to know this is
uh reconsideration oh I'm sorry 139 yes
okay thank you Mr chair uh Mr chair I'd
like to move that we reconsider with an
amendment House Bill 139
um regarding to Municipal boundaries for
uh renewable energy projects
which I recognize representative Thomas
second
been moved and seconded that we
reconsider
our decision earlier on House Bill 139
as you'll recall
we tried to come to a conclusion on that
bill we were unsuccessful and we arrived
at a conclusion of without
recommendation
since that time
I have worked with the ranking member to
create a possible Avenue for
compromise on this bill I've prepared an
amendment
and
that was the reason for calling for
reconsideration today
so I would like to hear any discussion
regarding whether we should reconsider
our action on House Bill 139. does
anybody have anything
to say
representative McWilliams
um thank you Mr chair um I would like to
say that uh this is a really great step
uh to moving forward with removing the
constraint on Municipal Geographic
boundaries to allow municipalities to
install potential solar array in a
neighboring town if their own town does
not have land or space or rooftops to do
it
my caucus has reviewed this amendment
and it's an excellent first step to at
least push forward allowing
municipalities to net meter outside of
their own geographic area
however upon discussion are our concerns
with this amendment is that there is a
requirement that the municipality own
the in this case likely solar panels
outright and generally the way that we
can make these projects pencil is by the
municipality doing a power purchase
agreement for the first five years and
then purchasing the array and so
therefore I would ask that we actually
close the reconsideration today and
reconsider on Tuesday with a further
amendment to allow some kind of a PPA
lease agreement to make it actually work
financially for these municipalities
just to reflect the realities of the
market thank you
representative naino Reynolds do you
have a comment
I do thanks Mr chairman yes
um I can speak from experience on this
of course having worked in this field
and I I really
believe that
I I think
that it's a good bill to remove the
artificial
uh constraint that you know of adjacency
Municipal boundaries group net metering
can take place anywhere within the same
ought to be able to take place
anywhere within a utilities service
territory because energy goes into the
grid it can be credited to customers
anywhere with respect to the situation
that representative
um McWilliams was just addressing I
think the bill should just remain silent
about
uh ownership structure uh and that we
here at the legislature should Empower
our our towns uh to enter into whatever
kind of
uh you know contracts Arrangements that
they
that they see fit uh in order to benefit
from from group net metering um you know
Town managers Town energy committees
stuff boards can can judge
the financial Arrangement and how it
works for them I don't think we should
put the constraint about they have to
own it because as as representative
McWilliams said the most frequent way is
for an investor to own it at first
because they can they're the ones that
can benefit from the tax credits that
are available and towns cannot so that's
okay it usually works let's not debate
the okay merits of the amendment because
we don't have an amendment before us yet
so are there any further comments on
whether or not we should reconsider this
bill or just leave it as is
my rationale behind reconsidering the
bill
was to
see if we could find a way
to compromise and come up with a with a
resolution
in order to get there I think we have to
vote to reconsider it
that reopens the exact session on the
bill
and we can then recess the exact session
to do further work on the amendment
if we deem that to be necessary but the
first step is to reconsider the decision
that we made
a week ago two weeks ago whenever it was
so representative McWilliams
thank you chair Vos I believe you're
correct that we do have to reconsider in
order to open it and so I would
recommend reconsider to open and then
recess at this point
any further discussion
representative Doug Thomas thank you Mr
chair uh every once in a while we come
across a situation where we uh vote one
way but then soon after we find out
there's maybe a path forward this is one
of those cases so I wholly support uh
voting in favor of reconsideration
representative closure
uh thank you chair I'm in a favor for I
look back on the notes we talked on 20
minutes before we decided to on the uh
bear with me
HBO 139 on February 3rd at
two o'clock we were talking on that to 2
20. I think a lot of things were said
then I I think there is reason to
reconsider this so yes I vote for it
further discussion
seeing Nana I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of
reconsideration of House Bill 139
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes
Andrew renzullo yes Roy murner yes Carol
Brown yes
Lex brezhny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
closure yes
James Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams yes
Joan hamblet yes yes
Jackie creation yes
lucious partial yes Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman Bose yes
20-0
okay by a vote of 20 to zero
we have decided to reconsider house bill
139.
that opens reopens the executive session
for house bill 139. and at the call of
the chair I'm going to recess
this executive session until March 7th
at a time to be determined
and with that
we'll close the public hearing on House
Bill
one three nine
and now we can move on
and
talk about the other bills before us
today
so now I'd like to open a exec session
on House Bill 208 or actually resume the
exact session on House Bill 208 and I
recognize representative Thomas for a
motion
thank you Mr chair
um I recommend itl on HB 208
. Jay recognizes representative naughter
I second the motion
it has been moved and seconded that we
judge House Bill 208 to be
referred to the floor as inexpedient to
legislate is there any discussion on
this
representative Thomas thank you Mr
Thomas thank you Mr chair
um we looked at this bill and a lot of
good points in it but we heard testimony
from Des that the bill doesn't address
funding that they estimate they would
need three additional staff members to
um uh to do what this bill would would
require them to do it would require a
rewrite of the of the of the energy plan
that do we has out there and that there
was too short a time that this Bill had
in here to do any of these things at all
and for these reasons I just don't think
the bill is quite ready and that's why I
recommend itl
further discussion on the motion to itl
house bill 208.
representative Christian
thank you chair
um I believe we tried to get an
amendment made that would deal with some
of the language issues and funding
issues that were brought forward I'm not
sure why that was not allowed to come
forward
um a few other points that I had wanted
to make in introducing this bill but
unfortunately was incapacitated and
unable to do
um
it's been said many times sorry that
it's a cliche but failing to plan is
planning to fail
um we do not have a
a real climate action plan a real plan
for the transition to renewable energies
currently and I think that this is you
know a real failure of our for our
constituents
um we have a fiduciary duty to our
constituents to pursue renewable energy
which will save money in the long term
I provided some information from a
recent study that was out last year in
the journal Jewel that showed
the difference between uh
pursuing Renewables early and pursuing
late and how much that will cost or save
us respectively
also you know we have a duty to our
constituents to protect the environment
remove particulates get away from fossil
fuels I think there are many reasons
that we need a a serious plan to
transition to renewable energies and
um
you know if we need to to make edits to
this bill to get that to happen I'm
absolutely open to that but I really
think we can't continue kicking this can
down the road thank you
thank you representative any further
discussion on the motion to itl House
Bill 208 representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair
um just looking at my notes during the
hearing the climate action plan would
also include the impact on environment
which is so important for any kind of
energy plan going forward and that seems
to be missing from some of the other
initiatives that we've talked about also
um this this uh
at climate action plan would look at the
economic impact on on property value
which is being affected with with the
climate change
further discussion representative Munds
as a comment thank you Mr chair I'd just
like to uh
um Echo what uh representative Christian
said about you know the importance of
having a plan and I would add that
um having this type of plan is also good
for New Hampshire business and for
continued economic development in our
state the one thing that businesses look
for when they're thinking about
investing in the future is some sense of
certainty of some plan as to what the
future looks like and
um I think it's very important that we
that we provide a a framework for how
the state plans to address climate
change and hopefully
make it give them some certainty as to
what they can expect as they're making
their investment decisions
further discussion
representative Kaplan
thank you Mr chair and I just want to
add to
the voices calling for a little bit of
wisdom from the legislature in terms of
looking forward into the future and
especially for young people in the state
who feel that
you know we as a legislature are a
little bit out of touch because of
various factors and maybe feeling that
they are not being represented and
you know the fact that we're not even
thinking about the largest threat uh
that they face in their future uh and as
a science technology and energy
committee
choosing to you know to follow a
cost-benefit short-term analysis that
that you know we can't even bring
ourselves to fund three positions in the
department of of uh of energy to oversee
people who would drop a plan I mean it's
it's just a little bit out of touch so I
feel that
we need to do something we need to do
better
further discussion
seeing none I asked the clerk to call
the role on the question of itl for
house bill 208.
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine naughter yes
Andrew manzullo yes Troy Marner yes
Carol Brown yes
like sproginy yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
plagee yes
James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams
no
Joan Hamlet
Jackie creation no
lucious partial no
Tony Kaplan no
Chris muns no
Henry Noel no Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Carmen no
Ned Reynolds
no chairman Bose yes
10 10.
buy a vote of 10 10 the motion to itl
House Bill 208 fails chair recognizes
representative McWilliams for a motion
I move OTP on HB 208
chair recognizes representative muns
second it's been moved and seconded that
we judge House Bill 208
as worthy of ought to pass is there any
further discussion
seeing none I'll ask representative
Reynolds to turn his mic off and then
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll on
the question of
OTP on House Bill 208
Doug Thomas no
Janine not her no
Andrew and zullo no
try Mariner no Carol Brown no
expressiony no JD Bernardi no Tom poche
no
James Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams yes
John Hamlet yes
Jackie creation yes
Lucia's partial yes Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Carmen yes
Ned Reynolds yes chairman Bose
sorry I lost track no
10 10. okay by a vote of 10 to 10
the motion of ought to pass fails
chair recognizes representative Doug
Thomas for a motion
uh Mr chair I recommend a motion to
retain
chair recognizes representative
McWilliams
Mr chair I move that we retain House
Bill 208
I was looking for a second that motion's
already on the floor sorry
okay it's been moved and seconded that
we retain House Bill 208
is there any further discussion
it's likely that having voted
10 10 on the two previous motions that
this motion will also come out as 10 10.
and if that should be the case this bill
will go to the house floor without
recommendation
see no further discussion I'll ask the
clerk to call the roll on the question
of retain for house bill 208.
Doug Thomas yes
no
you're you're
can we have a short time mode
my apologies no
wrong Bill
Janine nodder no
Andrew renzullo no
Brian Marner no
Carol Brown no
Lex prajni no
JD Bernardi no Tom plushie no James
Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams
yes
Joan Hamlet yes Jackie creation yes
loses partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Carmen yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman Vose no 10 10. by a vote of 10
to 10 this bill is voted uh or the
committee has voted not to retain this
bill therefore it will go to the house
floor without recommendation
so I'll close the exact session on House
Bill 208.
now I want to clarify for everyone's
edification here that
I was chastised by the house Clerk last
week or shortcutting the executive
session process it was explained to me
that if a motion fails 10 to 10 then you
have to go to the next motion if that
fails 10 to 10 then you have to go to
retain it's required and then if that
motion fails then the bill can come out
of committee without a without
recommendation so that's why we had
three separate votes on this bill
that's to keep me in the good graces of
the house Clerk
okay I may add that if we do this over
and over again I'm going to run out of
roll calls
okay
um
Christy is uh
Carey's still here
could you tell her we might need some
more reforms roll call forms thank you
yes representative McWilliams
in the interest of Expedia
I do appreciate what you were doing and
our
saying you would assume that the vote
would be the same whether it was OTP itl
retain is there a way that we can sort
of fast-track this and not spend the
extra seven minutes doing three votes
did the CH did the clerk give you any
best practices on this baby
representative uh he did not he he said
we have to go through the process he
said
let's say you vote itl first and it
comes out 10 10. he said you can't skip
the vote on OTP because somebody might
change their mind
so you have to take the vote
and the ditto with retain
somebody may change their vote and say
yeah let's keep this bill and look at it
again so you have to go through the
process all three steps
that's the way it was explained to me
anyway representative Doug Thomas yes Mr
chairman uh is it possible that we could
either do a either a Voice vote I'm
sorry maybe a hand vote to expediate the
process
I'll defer to the clerk on this one
during clerk training did they uh not a
subcommittees but not for uh that's what
I thought yeah yeah that's not allowable
for full committee uh executive session
votes so sorry good try
all right
with that clarification uh
explained so that everybody knows what
we're doing we will move on
and I will now resume the public hearing
on House Bill
298 and I recognize representative Doug
Thomas for a motion thank you Mr
chairman uh motion on HB 298 as is uh
OTP
and representative
Janine Nader is recognized for a
second the motion okay then seconded
that house bill 298 be judged to be OTP
I'm sorry porno of order I think you
said reopen the hearing not open the
executive session
thank you for that clarification
so the re the executive session for
House Bill 298 298 is now open
and I am going to offer an amendment
Amendment
zero five six five H which I am
passing out to the members of the
committee
as we speak or as I speak
what this amendment does is it
removes from the original bill
information uh or a requirement to adopt
ANSI and APCO codes
for
a application to or modification
application for wireless service
facilities
it also makes some changes to language
down in section two
it removes the word environmental from
line 20.
and it changes in line 24
a phrase that previously read
environmentally sensitive areas it
changed that phrase to horticulturally
sensitive areas
so that those are the substantive parts
of this
Amendment those are all the parts of the
amendment actually and uh
I offer this for adoption and would like
to hear your comments on the amendment
representative McWilliams
um thank you chair votes for the
amendment to this bill
um I know we've talked about the fact
that I have a background as an attorney
and so reading this with sort of a legal
lens I am really happy to see the change
specifically to line 24 to Define
historical or horticulturally sensitive
areas I do believe that that is
something a court of law could hold up
if there were a challenge about the
location of a 5G cell tower I was
concerned that environmental concerns
was just too wide-ranging for a court to
interpret and it may be stricken from
the uh from the statute and so therefore
I'm very happy with this amendment thank
you
further discussion on the amendment
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair
um I'm not trying to nitpick here I'm
just trying to
um see what's what's in this amendment
on line 24
um it's his horticulturally
sensitive areas but there's no hyphen so
is it historical sensitive as well as
horticulturally sensitive or is it just
horticulturally sensitive
okay I'm sorry I was distracted you're
complaining about the no I'm not
complaining I'm just asking a
clarification question so in the
original bill it was environmentally
hyphen sensitive areas but in this one
there's no hyphen so is it historical
sensitive as well as Horticultural Lee
sensitive
or is it horticulturally sensitive and
historical
I I asked the OLS attorney to put a
hyphen in there he did not
so all right so the sensitive just
belongs to the Horticultural yes thank
you okay okay
representative Corman thank you um I
actually directed The Dartmouth College
writing program so I'm very sensitive to
these issues because horticulturally is
no pun intended right
because horticulturally is an adverb it
cannot apply to areas so it applies only
to sensitive and therefore historical uh
does not so it's it's historical areas
or horticulturally sensitive areas
that's the correct interpretation
so you're saying the OLS attorney did it
correctly I am saying just that yes oh
excellent so excuse me are you saying
they did it wrong in the first bill
okay all right
it's it's a tiny little thing but good
enough that's settled that settled any
further comment representative muns
thank you Mr chair
um I noticed that your um Amendment also
deleted deletes the second paragraph of
the original bill
that was dealing I think with
um indemnification
is there can you maybe talk to that
yes I deleted everything after the
uh the word
or the words building electrical and
fire codes
because I they applied to the previous
or to the ANSI Adco or APCO whatever it
was a section of the of the bill follow
up on that that I apologize that's what
I wasn't I wasn't referring to that in
in the original Bill there is actually a
second paragraph a paragraph that comes
after the discussion of historical or
environmentally sensitive areas it talks
about adding a
a sub paragraph to deal with
um
a you know planning board can add um you
know I can just re I can read it if you
want me to no you don't need to because
now I understand your question yeah I
just was curious as to you know yeah the
answer to your question is if you read
line one of the amendment it says amend
the bill by replacing section one with
the following so this just
replaces section one but section two
remains intact thank you very much okay
thank you any further discussion on this
amendment representative partial
yes thank you chair I need to just add
one correction of some information I
supplied to Doug Thomas yesterday
I believe I stated incorrectly that this
thus applies to the
short range what is a small repeater
small so so
uh 5G
in fact this legislation will also apply
to macro Towers
and so the removal of that one Clause
may be of questionable nature but I will
not contest it right now
okay thank you very much any further
discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of adopting the
amendment
zero five six five h
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes Andrew
manzullo yes Troy Marner yes Carol Brown
yes Lex barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
poche yes James Summers yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes
Joan hamblet yes
Jackie creation yes
Lucia's partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes
Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas with or
without hyphen yes
Thomas Gorman yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman yes
20-0
okay by a vote of 20 to nothing the
amendment zero five six five H is
adopted that makes the motion on the
floor
OTP a
is there any discussion on this
motion
any further discussion
representative munz
thank you Mr chairman I and I would ask
the committee to Bear Indulgence to my
to me for a second I I'm
I have been struggling with why this
this bill is even necessary
um I I heard during testimony and I've
heard in conversations that I've been
part of that this is required this is
something that will give local
authorities
the ability to have greater oversight
over the placement of 5G
um
uh transmitters in in the community but
I've also heard that the local
authorities already have that Authority
and I've heard also that there's
extensive regulations that the FCC has
that governs where
um these transmitters can be placed so
I'm
and I'm just asking I'm asking anyone on
the committee that could maybe enlighten
me
um you know what Gap is this bill going
to fill
uh representative partial
as I have already done uh what I believe
was my best ability to explain where I
see the gap
would it be possible for me to call back
to the witness stand somebody to uh
maybe do a better job than I could have
explaining it
no we're in voting mode at this point so
that that won't work sorry
any uh further discussion
representative Reynolds will turn off
your microphone and representative
closures recognized
uh thank you chair if I believe
correctly the municipalities did not
have anything in writing
that they felt comfortable with to
challenge
the
Communications definition of
the Federal's rulings
it did not I believe it did not say now
someone needs to correct me I did not
have this in my minutes
but I believe
here we go I'm not supposed to believe
excuse me chair
the municipalities need
um a statue
to tell them they actually have
the authority to look into this with
engineering of their own I don't believe
that was out there that's why this bill
okay thank you further discussion on the
question of otpa on House Bill 298
representative notter
I still have a lot of reservations about
this bill and I've got a whole list of
questions and it would just it would
just take a long time can I hand this to
you and let you look it over for a few
minutes
I don't have time to look it over I can
look it over later if you like but
representative Corman had a question or
a comment yes thank you Mr chair uh just
to follow up on on representative munz's
question I'm looking through my notes
and um the first person the person who
introduced the bill was Senator richardi
and representative Doug Thomas did ask a
question about uh what this bill did in
terms of municipalities and Senator
richardi did say that it gives Clarity
to municipalities that are currently
confused because of what they hear from
industry telling them that they they
don't have any jurisdiction so if
nothing else this bill would help
clarify to municipalities what their
rights are
further discussion
seeing none I asked the clerk to call
the roll on the question of otpa
on House Bill 298.
Doug Thomas
no
Janine nodder no
Andrew renzullo no
Troy merner no
Carol Brown no
Lex brajny no JD Bernardi no Tom plushie
yes
James Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Joan hamblet yes
Jackie creation
yes
lucious partial
Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns no
Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds
yes
chair of those no
yay
oh three four five six seven eight nine
ten to ten
what was it 10 10.
by a vote of 10 to 10 the motion to
otpa fails
the chair recognizes representative
Thomas for a motion
thank you Mr chair motion itl
chair recognizes representative Bernardi
the second the motion it's been moved
and seconded that we itl House Bill 298
is there any further discussion
representative barajny
thank you chairman this is more of a
question uh based on the previous
questions but the FCC does not there's
not a lot of time to just forbid putting
Towers in their town so if you have if
you're required to have a tower
anyways this seems like this just adds a
roadblock but they have to allow a tower
to be built somewhere in town I guess if
anybody has a comment on that or if they
remember that from the testimony
further comment
representative muns
thank you Mr chair I just um wanted to
take this opportunity to just say that
um my opposition to this bill is I'm
very sympathetic to those that are
concerned about the um the placement of
these Wireless transmitters I I think
it's a legitimate concern and my vote
against adoption was based more on just
lack of clarity about what this was
really going to be doing in terms of uh
making it making it making that process
more seamless
thank you representative McWilliams
thank you charvos as a representative
who has a constituent Who currently does
not want a tower anywhere near his
agricultural field because there is
research coming out of unh Durham
regarding impacts on certain crops from
the wireless signals I certainly would
like to have something in statute that
he would be able to stand on in his
attempts to fight the location of the
tower near his field and so for that
reason I really feel like we need to
have something that our constituents can
lean on if they're going to be able to
fight a tower thank you
seeing no further discussion I'll ask
the clerk to call the roll on the
question of itl for house bill 29er8
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes Andrew ranzullo yes
Troy murner yes Carol Brown yes Lex
brajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom pleasure
yes
James Summers yes
uh Rebecca McWilliams no
Handler no
Jackie creation no
lucious partial no Tony Kaplan nope
Chris muns no
Henry Noel no
Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Corman no
Ned Reynolds no
chairman Vose
yes
10 10 by a vote of 10 to 10 the motion
to itl
fails
chair recognizes representative Thomas
for a motion
uh thank you Mr chairman uh motion to
retain
recognize representative naughter
yes Mr chairman
I'll second the motion for you it's been
moved and seconded that we retain House
Bill 298 is there any discussion
representative cretian
thank you chair
um I know that we had a bill I'm not
sure if it counts as substantively
similar but but on the topic of 5G Tower
citing last year
um That Was Then retained for a study
committee over the the interim
um we've gotten to this point to an
amendment that we can't seem to agree on
I'm not sure that retaining would have a
purpose
further discussion on the question of
retaining House Bill 298
so you not asked the clerk to call the
role in the question of retain for house
bill 298.
Doug Thomas
no
Janine naughter no
Andrew renzullo no
Troy Marner
no Carol Brown no
Lex brajney no JD Bernardi no Tom
plushie no
James Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams no
Joan hamblet no
tacky creation no
it was just partial no Tony Kaplan no
Chris muns yes
Henry Noel no
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Carmen no
Ned Reynolds
no
chairman Vose no
2 to 18.
by a vote of 18 to 2 or 2 to 18 to be
more correct the motion to retain is
defeated
therefore this bill will go to the house
floor
without recommendation
and the first motion on the floor will
be otpa
so with that
we'll conclude the executive session on
House Bill 298.
next up
and we'll open a exact session on how
spill two three three dash FN
relative to useful thermal energy under
the renewable portfolio standard
and I will move on this bill
OTP
and I'll recognize representative Thomas
second
it's been moved and seconded that we
pass judgment on House Bill
233 as ought to pass and I offer
Amendment
zero five seven six H which is
circulating
to each of you as I speak
this amendment
implements the recommendation of the
Department of energy to
to put into statute
a bifurcation of large
systems and small thermal systems
and further
makes those small systems
eligible to receive thermal wrecks
without having to
use a meter to determine their
eligibility
their eligibility instead shall be
verified by a method that is
satisfactory to the Department of energy
in order to calculate the quantity of
megabot hours for which renewable energy
certificates are qualified
so this is a essentially the same bill
only using different language and it's
language that has been vetted by the
department of energy and recommended by
the department of energy
is there any discussion on the adoption
of this amendment
representative Thomas
thank you Mr chairman uh we heard
testimony from several people and
businesses in the wood industry in favor
of this um Bill and this amendment just
just makes it better we need to um
offer some relief to our small business
would people where these meters are very
expensive and they do provide a service
to our forests and to their uh to uh
jobs as well I think this is a good
Amendment so I would recommend everyone
support it please
further discussion
representative Reynolds
yeah I just would second uh what
representative Thomas just said I I
think it we ought to be encouraging and
making it more possible for small
uh small wood burners
to capitalize on on the wrecks so I
think this is a good Improvement
further discussion
question
representative Bernardi has a question
the question does this get down to the
level of potentially uh residential uh
pellet burning or no yes those would
qualify as small systems yes okay thank
you I'd remind members that the purpose
of this bill was to increase the number
of T-Rex thermal wrecks that are
available
for utilities to purchase so that they
don't have to make alternative
compliance payments instead
acps are more expensive so if they can
buy thermal Wrecks for less money it
brings down the cost to ratepayers
representative Nutter
thank you Mr chairman during the hearing
I had asked a question about a single
class of RPS and
the guy was was kind of taken aback by
that question and I said well it's come
up before in in committee and I just
thought it was interesting that I found
a note in my notebook from I don't even
know how many terms ago where we did
discuss classless RPS so I just wanted
to bring that up
any further discussion on
amendment number
zero five seven six h
uh seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the roll on the question of the
adoption of the amendment zero five
seven six H Doug Thomas yes Janine
nodder yes
Andrew and zullo yes Troy Mariner yes
Carol Brown
yes
yes JD Bernardi yes Tom pleasure yes
James Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams no
John Hamlet no
Jackie creation no lucious partial
yes
Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes
Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes chairman Rose
yes
Seventeen three by a vote of 17-3 the
amendment is adopted that makes the
motion on the floor
otpa is there any further discussion on
that question
okay I'll ask representative Thomas for
a motion
otpa
representative nodder a second the
motion moved and seconded to otpa
house bill 233 any further discussion
representative notter just a quick point
that the list of
sponsors are it's bipartisan
thank you
any further discussion
representative Kaplan you may want to
turn off your mic
representative Krishan sorry that this
is a question
um since I wasn't here for the
discussion
um is there a concern that creating more
T-Rex without making some sort of
commensurate change to the RPS standards
is going to
either flood the uh Market with Rex and
make them each less expensive or
generally depress the
to press the market for for wrecks and
um
discourage investment in other renewable
sources
no there was no concern about that at
all in fact there's a shortage of T-Rex
right now and last year the utilities
made 2.8 million dollars of ACP payments
because they couldn't find T-rex to buy
so there's was no concern expressed
about t-rex suddenly flooding the market
and bringing down the cost of other
wrecks
any further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of OTP slash a
for House Bill 233
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes
Andrew and Zillow yes Troy merner yes
Carol Brown yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom pleasure yes
James Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams yes
Joan Hamlet yes
Jackie creation
no
lucious partial
yes
Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes
Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas
Corman yes Ned Reynolds yes
yes
19-1
by a vote of 19-1 the committee judges
house bill 233 to be worthy of OTP a
and
because this is a dash FN bill
I think it cannot go on the consent
calendar
unfortunately correct
okay
so that will conclude the exact session
on House Bill 2 33.
so we haven't been identified who's
going to be writing the reports we want
to do that at the end
the clerk reminds me that we need to
identify who's going to be writing
reports
so
on this bill I will write the report for
otpa
representative McWilliams will there be
a Minority Report not for this one no
no Minority Report on this bill all
right let's backtrack and do the bills
that we did before House Bill
208 who will write the OTP
recommendation on that one
application
otpa yes
now that's Doug Thomas
and will there be a Minority Report well
there has to be because it was 298 or
208. 208. did I say 98 I misspoke I'm
sorry is uh Jackie Christian's Bill she
will be writing a report I'm not sure
how you want to characterize it the
other side right
so Doug Thomas will write the report for
itl and Jackie Cresson we'll write the
port report for
OTP
okay on uh house bill
298.
I'll take that one
so
Lucius partial we'll write the
OTP position yes
and
representative Doug Thomas will write
the
itl position
okay
all right so now we're caught up House
Bill 233 is done
so now
we'll move on
now open an exact session on House Bill
2 5 7.
this is a bill that's relative to
telephone carrier of Last Resort
obligations
representative munz has requested a
recess
on this executive session and the
formation of a study committee
to see if we can come up with a solution
for this bill
so
I will so order and ask for volunteers
to serve on a
study committee on house bill 257.
representative munz is on the study
committee
winner buns
murder
yeah
Corman
additional volunteers Wendy Thomas
one two three four we need one more we
need an odd number
um
representative Summers
yes okay
all right so the study committee on this
bill
will be Munds Mariner Corman Wendy
Thomas and Summers
and we will recess this executive
session until March 7th
so that means any compromise that you
come up with
has to be an amendment has to be
delivered by the 7th of March
okay
so we won't close that executive session
because it's simply recessed
but we're done with it for now
so next we move on to House Bill 251
and I recognize representative Thomas
for a motion
thank you Mr chair I recommend OTP on HB
251 chair recognizes representative
notter
second
it's been moved and seconded that we
judge House Bill 251 to be worthy of
ought to pass is there any discussion
representative Thomas yes thank you Mr
chair I offer Amendment
uh put some of the Amendments here I
offer Amendment uh 2023-054h
and the amendment basically
adds one more requirement to what is
already on the December
um electric bills for utilities across
the state which is to it it adds the
dollar figure of the
say this right the dollar figure of the
average cost of RPS uh throughout the
state so on your electric bill you will
have somewhere on there will have not
only your kilowatt basis for the RPS uh
annualized as a estimate of the of the
average but you'll also have the dollar
figure of what it represents
um if I may uh should I just read the
appropriate line that changes this
uh yeah this was um this amendment was
um written to and agreed to by members
of doe and all four utilities and I'll
just read the Salient point on lines 13
to 17 where it says this was added to
the to the bill utilities shall also be
required to include an annual estimated
cost to be calculated by multiplying the
average per kilowatt hour cost of the
electric renewable portfolio standard
under RSA 362f for the prior compliance
Year by the average residential monthly
consumption of 225 kilowatt hours so I
think during
during testimony it was it was stated
that approximately uh for I think was
for 625 kilowatt hours the annual cost
the average cost was around 39 dollars
so if someone uses a thousand kilowatt
hours for uh um or if someone can just
take that figure and multiply their
their uh their monthly bills they can
come up with their with their total cost
for their particular bill but at least
this gives them a basis to average by
you know so
uh you know and the important key
question on this was answered the
utility said that this would be done at
no additional cost to the repair
so it's a win-win there
did you pass out copies to all members
no I well uh I think uh they were passed
out plus I emailed them out to everybody
last night
okay
uh discussion on the amendment number
zero five
four eight H representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair
um just clarification on the amendment I
don't have it in front of me
um is it the same message on the bill
every month or is it just on the
December bill you
thank you for the question it would be
just for the December bill because it
would show the the um the average the
entire prior compliance year yeah thank
you
further discussion on the amendment
representative munz is recognized thank
you Mr chair
um
I I
I'm struggling with the fact that we're
we're doing a calculation using an
average number why can't we do the
calculation using the actual consumption
of the each individual customer
well if I may answer uh
that was the that was my original want
three years ago uh but in discussion
with the utilities uh I was informed
that that
would actually cost money they would
have to
um revise some part of their software
Billing System for each individualized
electric bill and I think uh three or
four years ago they were estimating it'd
be about two million dollars this year
is probably more with inflation but um
we wanted something for for um
to have people give some idea of what
they might be paying if they were
interested this gives a little bit
easier so in the interest of a
compromise we felt that having the
annual
number on here at least is another step
towards the towards the purpose of
transparency so but it was basically a a
cost factor that would have been applied
to the repairs follow up
but it's misleading it it it's
misleading unless unless somebody
consumes 650 megawatt hours or 625
megawatt hours it's not it's not doesn't
say anything in terms of what their
individual consumption is
and what their what the what the cost is
to them
you're partially right there uh they
would have to do a little bit of math to
um to figure out what their actual
payment was but in my opinion and also
in uh in talking to doe and also uh
knowing uh members on the other side of
the wall uh this is something this is a
step that we can get done and it's just
one more step and
um to go further uh would probably
jeopardize the entire bill so I would
rather have this one step done now and
then maybe next year we can look at how
we might be able to get a little more
accurate
notion there but I think for right now
this at least gives a little more
information than just having cents per
kilowatt hours on there so that's I
think it's the best we can get right now
and since this cents per kilowatt hour
number is going to be printed on the
bill any customer who cared could
calculate out his actual usage for
himself
representative munz
I I agree with you completely so instead
of putting a misleading number on why
not just put a note on the bill that
says to calculate your the annual cost
of the renewable portfolio standard
multiply this number by your your kwh
usage
I think the reason not to do that is
because the vast majority of people just
couldn't be bothered to do that but they
might be interested to know that they're
paying roughly 39 or whatever the number
is every year for compliance with the
RPS representative Thomas yes I actually
asked that question and
a lot of the billing systems software
are decades old and they deal with
limited characters
and to increase the characters would
increase expense
so that's that's the truth that's the
truthful answer
additional comments representative
Christian has a comment
thank you um just wanted to agree with
representative munz that I really don't
see any value in providing an average
that the customer would then have to
back calculate from when it would be
much simpler to Simply multiply by the
kilowatt hour rate that's already
provided
um but also I'm concerned that this
amendment seems to be kind of
self-contradictory in a few areas
um so it says you know the estimated
cost for the compliance year shall be
calculated once per year
um that to me sounds like it applies to
the actual customers cost not the the
average there's also still language
saying that the cost for a utility to
provide this information will be
recovered from Electric customers which
I know we all are not interested in
adding to to and as representative
Thomas said
um
sounds like there shouldn't be any costs
anyway so I'm not sure why that is still
in the bill
well if if you notice that um the last
part is not in bold so that's already
part of the of the RSA so that wasn't
changed at all it's it's been in effect
now for
even even longer than when the first
change was made three years ago
representative Corman has a comment
thank you Mr chair uh I'm in the
minority here that gets uh bills from
Liberty my bill has the previous 12
months on it so that information is
already available when they are sending
me the bill
um I know a little bit about writing
code AS do many people here and it's
pretty easy to add up 12 numbers and
then multiply them by something and just
put that on the bill so the assertion
that it would be two million dollars of
software I see representative smiling I
know he has a software background uh the
idea that it's a two million dollar
change
I'm not buying it
I'm not either we have inflation now
representative Reynolds has a question
or a comment well yes I have a I have a
comment my my objection to this to this
bill
and this amendment I really could care
less which
cost we're talking about
putting on customers bills whether it's
their actual cost based on their actual
usage or whether it's their the average
cost
um my objection to this bill is that
it's telling one side of the story
it's clear that the objective of this
bill is to as a couple of members have
stated already is to present customers
with a number on their bill a cost that
quote shows them the cost to them of
the renewable portfolio standard the
problem is we would not be presenting
them with any information about the
commensurate benefit of the renewable
portfolio standard the presumed reason
that we have such a public policy in the
state of New Hampshire I I do note that
that number would would appear on their
bill with a link to information about
the electric renewable portfolio
standard including its benefits at the
public utility commission's website
however that seems pretty lopsided
we can all imagine the fraction of rate
payers who seeing this information on
their bill are going to immediately
Scurry to the puc website to read about
the benefits of the renewable portfolio
standard you know in the spirit of
bipartisanship I would be open
uh to an amendment to reworking this
bill
perhaps not now but in you know if we
retain it to um
not only present rate payers with this
cost information but also present them
with information such as that which was
shared with us by the New England uh ISO
which showed
that behind the meter solar
reduces
Regional demand and how much that
reduction in Regional demand reduces
costs for all rate payers that would be
a more balanced way to inform and
actually educate rate payers about our
public policies related to renewable
energy
so you're opposed to transparency then
oh no I'm in favor of transparency I'm
in favor of full and balanced
transparency that's what this bill does
it provides transparency for people to
know what they're paying representative
Mr chairman it would provide that but it
wouldn't provide them any information
about how they're benefiting from that
cost in other words it would provide
them the cost of their investment but
not their return on their investment if
they're interested in that there's a
link they can go to representative Wendy
Thomas
thank you um
oh boy uh with
um I I believe my colleague to the right
of me um has some valid points but um I
also think that see there's
no detriment to seeing an average cost
because then you could take the two
numbers and figure out how you compare
to that average cost and
um I think the more information that's
provided the better although I I do
think that um
that putting benefits would be
appropriate but but I
I think the average cost I'm okay with
that
okay seeing no further discussion on
this bill I'd ask the clerk to call the
role on the question of the adoption of
amendment
zero two zero five four eight h
uh Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes
Andrew and zullo yes try Marner yes
Carol Brown yes Lex barajny no
JD Bernardi yes Tom closure yes
James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Joan hamblet yes
Jackie creation no
loser's partial no
Tony Kaplan no
Chris muns no
Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Carmen no
Ned Reynolds no
chairman Vose yes
thirteen to seven
by a vote of 13 to 7 the amendment is
adopted
chair recognizes representative Thomas
for a motion
thank you Mr chair I'm ocean otpa
chair recognizes representative Bernardi
second the motion it's been moved and
seconded that we judge House Bill 251 to
be
otpa any further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the quest roll on the question of otpa
for house bill 251.
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes
Andrew and zullo yes try Marner yes
Carol Brown yes Lex barajny yes
JD Bernardi yes Tom pleasure yes James
Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams no
Jackie creation
no
John Hamlet no
lucious partial no Tony Kaplan nope
Chris Munns nope
Henry Noel no
Wendy Thomas oh God uh yes
Thomas Corman no
Ned Reynolds no
chair of those yes
eleven to nine
by a vote of 11 to 9
the
House Bill 251 will be going to the
house floor with a recommendation of
ought to pass as amended representative
Thomas will write the
majority report will there be any
Minority Report uh representative
McWilliams representative Reynolds
representative Reynolds will write the
minority reports
okay
we will now close the executive session
on House Bill 251
and since it is almost 2 30
we'll take a five minute recess I'll let
everybody
stretch their legs a bit and relax and
then we'll come back and do House Bill
263 FN
AF
yes
thank you
very much
questions
Detroit
experience
foreign
thank you
okay folks let's take our seats and get
back to work here
okay
foreign
let's get back to work
I'll open a exact session on House Bill
263fn requiring notification to
Renewable Energy customer generators
issues related to Renewable Energy
Credit credits and I'll recognize
representative Bernardi for a motion
moved to itl
recognize representative Thomas
second it's been moved and seconded that
we itl house bill 263.
looking forward discussion on the
question
representative Bernardi
so
in the grand scheme of things I don't
think this is uh this is worth
worthwhile project if you know
if you have renewable equipment as I do
I know already I can apply for a wreck
or not it's part of getting the
installation I don't need someone to
send me a little notice about it so I
think this is just a waste of time
further discussion on the question of
itl for House Bill 263 FN
representative McWilliams
thank you chair Rose the intention of
this bill is very clear it's to provide
notification regarding Rec sweeping to
Consumer generators which is usually a
residential rooftop it's just one more
effort to make people who are creating
wrecks aware that they are creating
wrecks and if they do not fill out the
paperwork and apply to have those wrecks
as their own there will be a taking the
Rex will be swept to the energy
companies and this is very important
from a legal perspective because without
notice it's an illegal taking with
notice we have enabled by Statute for
this practice to continue for the last
12 years and so this leaves a loophole
in our current statute where wrecks are
being swept without notice from
consumers who have installed solar and
lost the paperwork ran out of time
didn't think about it had a hundred
things on their mind and one more
reminder would put them on notice
therefore I believe that this bill is a
good way to notify people who are
producing solar potential Rec
certificates that they have a right to
have them and if they don't it's going
to go and the monetary value is going to
go to a large out-of-state company thank
you further comment on House Bill 263
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair we just spent a little bit of time
quite a bit of time talking about a bill
that provided transparency on the uh the
bill that you get from the utilities to
the consumers this is just another
notification that is that provides
transparency to the consumers
thank you further comment representative
Christian
I was just going to say the same exact
thing um are we against transparency or
are we not against transparency thank
you
further comments representative barishni
yep thank you chairman uh in the
previous Bill we actually modified it to
have it be cost less and I think you
know provide transparency and still be
as economical as possible this bill will
likely have an expense to it so that's
why I'm against it
thank you for their comments
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the question
of itl for house bill
to uh
63.
Doug Thomas yes Denise yes Andrew and
Zillow yes try Mariner yes Carol Brown
yes Lex barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
pleasure yes
James Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams no
John Hamlet no
Jackie creation no Lewis just partial no
Tony Kaplan nope Chris muns nope Henry
Noel no
Wendy Thomas no Thomas Carmen no Ned
Reynolds No chairman Bose yes 10 10. by
a vote of 10 to 10 the motion of itl
fails chair recognizes representative
McWilliams for a motion
uh Mr chair I move OTP on this bill
representative McWilliams moves OTP
representative munz is recognized second
it's been moved and seconded that we
judge House Bill 263 to be worthy of
ought to pass is there any further
discussion
representative Christian
do you have just one more Point um a few
minutes ago maybe an hour ago at this
point we
um just
ruled otpaa on a bill that would create
a large number of wrecks including from
a small residential customers of thermal
energy I think that it would be
particularly important to have
notification given that we are going
down this route thank you
further comments representative Kaplan
yeah thank you Mr given the that the
practice of sweeping the wrecks
is of dubious legality I think the least
we can do is try to lessen our exposure
to this practice by providing
notification to the people who might be
affected
thank you
representative Mick Williams
thank you chair Bose I want to note for
the record that the practice of wreck
sweeping has decimated the market for
solar wrecks we're hearing from
Department of energy that there is an
abundance of wrecks because the
suppliers are getting free credits
against their obligations so everyone's
selling Rex has to accept lower prices
or sell out of state to get a decent
return or in many cases choose not to
participate because it's not worth it so
we've created a chicken and egg
situation renewable energy in New
Hampshire has been hobbled for a decade
we're talking about climate mitigation
issues and hurting Children's Health by
not addressing the concerns for our
addiction to Natural Gas much of this
could be resolved by making it very
abundantly clear to people installing
solar that they can do their part by
keeping their wrecks rather than giving
them to a utility instead so that they
can then get around the need to purchase
something for the renewable portfolio
standard requirement so for all of these
reasons we're talking about tens of
millions of dollars in benefit to
competitive suppliers who provide no
benefit to the ratepayers and this is a
huge harm that's been caused to our rate
payers and will continue to be caused to
our ratepayers it's unconscionable this
bill is a first step to at least provide
notice to meet a bare minimum legal
standard thank you
additional comment
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the question of ought to pass on House
Bill 263.
Doug Thomas
no
Janine knotter no
Andrew and zullo no try Mariner no Carol
Brown nope Lex prajni no JD Bernardi no
accomplish no James Summers no Rebecca
McWilliams yes
Joan Hamlet yes Jackie creation yes
Lucia's partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Carmen yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman Vose no 10 10. I have out of 10
10 the motion to OTP House Bill 263
fails
chair recognized as representative
Thomas for a motion
thank you Mr chair motion is to retain
chair recognizes representative Bernardi
second the motion it's been moved and
seconded that we retain House Bill 263
FN is there any discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of retain for
house bill 263.
Doug Thomas yes uh no no
Janine knotter no
Andrew ranzillo no Troy murder no Carol
Brown
no black expressiony no JD Bernardi no
Tom poche no James Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Stone hambley yes
Jackie creation
no
it's just partial yes
Tony Kaplan no
Chris muns yes
Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas this Thomas votes yes
foreign no
Ned Reynolds yes
chair of those no
one two three four five six seven
to thirteen
by a vote of seven to thirteen
the motion to retain fails this bill
will go to the house floor without
recommendation
representative Bernardi well you write
the uh
itl position yes
and representative McWilliams who do you
want to write the
ought to pass position myself
Rebecca McWilliams will write the ought
to pass position
with that we'll close the public the
executive session on House Bill 263
next we'll open an executive session on
House Bill 281
relative to least cost integrated
integrated resource plans and
the chair recognizes representative
Bernardi for a motion
I move itl representative Thomas is
recognized
second moved and seconded that we itl
house bill 281.
discussion on the motion representative
Bernardi
do two things at one time here
we'll come back to you
representative Corman thank you Mr chair
um this bill was presented to us as uh
as really applying to Electric utilities
but it also these least cost integrated
resource plans also apply to Gas
Utilities natural gas lines and it seems
to me that we really do need to be
planning for those so all issues about
electrical utilities aside whether that
that generation might not be covered
that that transmission might not be
covered that all that's left is
distribution whether or not I even buy
that I feel like because the gas lines
are
part of this plan I agree with the itl
motion
seconds
okay representative Bernardi's
recognized Mr uh chair I would like to
withdraw my emotion
and move OTP
representative Bernardi withdraws his
motion
representative Thomas Doug Thomas do you
withdraw your second
I do
representative Bernardi moves
OTP representative Thomas second
now we have moved and seconded the
motion of OTP on House Bill 281. now we
need discussion it's a different motion
apologize for the mix-up
so Mr representative Bernardi yes as as
uh
as the this bill was presented there
were several uh concerns uh but
um there was still value in moving
forward with uh this this bill so
I I want I want us to consider that
as I recall the department of energy
uh testified in favor of repealing these
least cost integrated resource plans
further discussion representative Wendy
Thomas uh thank you
um my concern with this bill is that
it's the only place where there's the
review of the environmental impact and
by getting rid of this we
remove reference to the Clean Air Act
and
it's it's that's those are very
important aspects that should not be
removed so thank you
during testimony we heard that these
least cost integrated resource plans
have not been filed for years so none of
that environmental planning is being
done
representative Reynolds they could be
representative Reynolds thank you Mr
chairman um
my
recollection is that we heard a lot of
testimony
saying that
while some aspects of integrated
resource planning
as currently
defined in statute
have been
obviated by the move by deregulation
um that there were also several aspects
of it that were still valuable and that
generally I thought the advice we
received was that the
rather than abolish IRP wholesale that
we ought to improve it so
I would be against
um passage of this bill which is a huge
stroke just ending a practice that has
has some value
thank you
representative Bernardi
yes thank you chair as as I recall yes
there were indeed some potential
advantages but the bill as written was
calling for things that that
realistically cannot yet still be done
and therefore it would be far better to
craft new legislation addressing that
those issues that are still relevant and
and move forward with ought to pass on
this
additional comments representative
McWilliams
just having some confusion about the
underlying motion this is an OTP on
House Bill 281 that's the motion I just
want to confirm that yes the bill
repeals the least cost integrated
resource planning statute okay so um
speaking to that the the statute right
now has the puc look at all cost saving
measures including Energy Efficiency and
diversity of energy resources
the goal here is to keep costs down for
ratepayers and we keep hearing over and
over that costs are off the charts so
getting rid of the least cost integrated
resource plan regardless of whether or
not it's actually been used or
implemented it's been on the books for
decades getting rid of that is eroding
the whole intention of protecting rate
payers and finding diverse Investments
we did hear from the office of the
consumer Advocate with the proposed
four-page amendment I think that there
is something here to perhaps revise the
statute and make it more modern and
applicable annually I'd love to see a
bill come forward next year to do just
that but I don't see anything here in
terms of repealing whole cloth something
that has been on the books for this long
and has the potential to really keep us
in line with economic good business
practices I I don't see it repealing as
a good idea at this point so I would
oppose an OTP motion
additional comments
representative partial
I would also add that not only our
consumer Advocate to increase but also
other source clf and the nature
conservator also believed favored reform
of the existing uh Bill rather than
let's see actually rather than uh
dissolving it entirely I think we have
nothing to replace it with and I think
it's foolhardy to in this time of when
we're challenged to acquire more
affordable energy to throw something
like this to the wind
representative Christian has a comment
I'll just agree that from my recent
experience it's uh nice when something
is broken you should try to fix it not
chop it off completely so we shouldn't
be repealing this entire statute thank
you
it's possible that the fastest way to
get a new modernized plan would be to
get rid of the old plan
okay any further comment
representative muns
um I
I believe we should not get rid of this
this statute but
um
to those that have said you know we need
a we need to update the plans or modify
the plans then I would suggest that
rather than repealing this provision we
take our we take some time perhaps
retain this bill and look at making it
better but let's not throw the baby out
with the bath water until we have an
alternative
foreign
comment
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the question of
OTP on House Bill 281.
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine knotter yes Andrew manzullo yes
Troy Marner yes Carol Brown yes Lex
barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom plushie
yes James Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams
no Joan hamblet no
Jackie creation no lucious partial no
Tony Capital no response no Henry Noel
no Wendy Thomas no Thomas Corman no Ned
Reynolds No chairman Vose
yes 10 10. my vote of 10 10 the motion
to OTP House Bill 281 fails chair
recognizes Rebecca McWilliams
Mr chair I move itl on this bill
chair recognizes representative muns
second
it's been moved and seconded that we itl
House Bill 281 any further discussion
see none I asked the clerk to call the
roll on the question of itl on House
Bill 281.
Doug Thomas no
Janine naughter no
Andrew ranzullo no try Marner no Carol
Brown no Lex brezhny no JD Bernardi no
Tom closure no James Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams yes Joan Hamlet yes
Jackie creation yes
lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Christmas yes Henry Noel
yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes chairman Vose No 10 10.
by a vote of 10 to 10 the motion to itl
House Bill 281 fails chair recognizes
representative Thomas for a motion thank
you Mr chairman motion to retain
representative Nader is recognized
second been moved and seconded that we
retain House Bill
281 discussion please
representative Corman thank you Mr chair
I think this is a the way to go we do
think that there's a way to improve this
bill and I think this is the best way to
go
I would just remind remembers members
that if we retain a bill we have to take
it up in the fall
which could involve several trips to
Concord during the fall
and uh so far we've retained several
bills already just want everyone to be
mindful of that representative cretian
it sounds like there are already some
fixes potentially in the works from the
office of the uh
oh my gosh consumer Advocate
um and I for one don't mind making an
extra trip up to Concord but that's just
me thank you
okay further discussion
representative Wendy Thomas thank you um
it it certainly sounds from the
discussion like there's an appetite to
update this to make it more modern
um so I don't know I mean when we retain
could we form a committee to look at
this as well or is that separate
for a bill like this there likely will
be a full committee work session
to discuss what to do with this retained
Bill thanks
representative Kaplan has a comment yeah
I'll just uh chime in to say that uh you
know given our concern with lowering
rates for uh for our for our
constituents and you know looking at the
least cost sources of energy I think
it's well worth looking at maybe trying
to update this plan so that's it's uh
applicable to the pra the practices that
the utilities are undertaking at this
point so yeah I think we should retain
it
further comments
seeing none I asked the clerk to call
the roll on the question of retain for
house bill
281.
Doug Thomas no
Janine nodder no
Andrew ranzillo no Prime earner no Carol
Brown nope like sprechny no JD Bernardi
no Tom plushie no James Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams yes
uh Joan Hamlet yes
uh Jackie creation yes
Lucia's partial yes Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes Wendy
Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes Ned
Reynolds yes chairman Bose no 10-10 by a
vote of 10 10 the motion to retain House
Bill 281 fails
this bill will go to the house floor
with no recommendation
the
first motion on the floor will be OTP
representative Bernardi will write the
position for
OTP representative McWilliams who will
write the
calendar report for itl
representative Wendy Thomas
who
representative Wendy Thomas Wendy Thomas
okay
all right so let's close the public
hearing on House Bill I mean the
executive session on House Bill 281
representative Brown uh thank you Mr
chair could I ask the folks on that side
of the room to speak up a little bit
we've got the the device running over
here and we're having a little bit of a
hard time hearing y'all thank you
maybe just get a little closer to the
mic when you speak
and actually if uh representative
McWilliams could get a little closer to
her mic when she speaks there you go
thank you very much
okay excellent
all right now we'll open an exec session
on House Bill 443
which is establishing a commission to
study the withdrawal of New Hampshire
from ISO New England and I'll recognize
representative Bernardi for emotion
no oh you got it
great
thank you
Mr chair I move OTP
representative Doug Thomas is recognized
second
it's been moved and seconded that we
move we judge
HB 443 to be ought to pass and the chair
recognized representative Bernardi for
an amendment
thank you Mr chair yes uh I have an
amendment that addresses
the issues that were raised in the
discussion uh that being that the time
frame of the commission was too short it
extends the time frame uh to the end of
2024 rather than the end of 2023 and it
adds uh 25 000
for Contract Services by the commission
so I believe this addresses all the key
issues that were raised during the
hearing
so representative Bernardi moves the
adoption of amendment
0572h is there discussion on this
question
representative berezny has a comment
thank you I guess just a question is
twenty five thousand dollars enough to
do
um the study or
um is that where does that number come
from and is that enough
that number was an estimate of What
charges may be we we also will have the
reports from Connecticut and Maine to
build on so we don't have to repeat a
lot of that work so the Assumption was
that this might be sufficient to do the
task
further comment representative Wendy
Thomas
um yeah I just have three things to say
um about just this study which repeats
what Maine has already done and in
leaving ISO New England in general I
believe that this amendment is
ridiculous ill thought and non-feasible
would you tell us what you really think
actually I'd appreciate
um
maybe a little more decorum in your
remarks than
that
any further comments on this amendment
representative McWilliams
yeah I don't I don't see a source of the
funds for twenty five thousand dollars
I'm a little concerned where it's going
to come from
it would come from the general budget
it doesn't say that
well that's what OLS gave me as a
funding source and when I spoke to them
that's what they said it would be a line
item in the general budget if this
passed
further discretion representative
partial has a comment to the same point
I don't see where uh what costs are
Justified and spending this sum of 25
000 I don't see any justification for
that about
further comments representative Kaplan
you know we're concerned thank you Mr
chair uh you know given our concern for
uh saving costs I just hate to see
public money spent on a study
uh that would lead to a conclusion that
that the whole idea is non-feasible from
the start so why why even spend 25 000
on on a study
further comments
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the question of the adoption of the
amendment zero five seven two H to house
bill 443.
Doug Thomas yes Janine knotter yes
Andrew and Zillow yes try Marner yes
Carol Brown yes
Lex barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
plazier yes
James Summers
yes
Rebecca McWilliams no
Joan hamblet no
Jackie creation no lucious partial no
Tony Kaplan nope Chris muns nope Henry
Noel
no
Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Carmen no
Ned Reynolds No chairman Bose yes 10-10
by Emotion by a vote of 10 to 10 the
motion is not adopted
chair recognizes representative barnardi
for emotion
that's on the main ATM yeah
uh Mr chairman I move on to pass on the
main bill
chair recognizes representative Doug
Thomas
second moved and seconded that the bill
be judged ought to pass
Is there further discussion
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman now that this bill
has a
potential twenty five thousand dollar
cost attached to it I'll
weigh in and say
yeah that failed oh
yeah didn't we just amend it the
amendment failed sorry sorry
you withdrew your comment representative
okay representative Christian
well now that there is no mechanism to
fund any sort of research for the study
it seems unfeasible to me
further comment
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of OTP for HB
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine otter yes
Andrew ranzillo yes Brian Werner yes
Carol Brown yes well expiration yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom plushie yes James
Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams no
Joan Hamlet no
Jackie creation no
no lucious partial no Tony Kaplan nope
Christmas nope Henry Noel no Wendy
Thomas no Thomas Corman no Ned Reynolds
No chairman Bose
10 10.
by a vote of 10 10 the motion to
OTP House Bill 443 fails
representative McWilliams is
recognized for emotion
uh Mr chair I I move that we um
well we tried OTP we try to itl Let's
retain this bill
we haven't it held it let's 1010 an itl
on this bill
foreign second
and moved and seconded that we itl House
Bill 443
any further discussion needed
representative partial
in light of our speaker
any further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role for the question of Ito for
House Bill 443. Doug Thomas
yes
I said yes
Andrew renzullo yes try Marner yes
Carol Brown yes well expressiony yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom closure yes
James Summers
this is itl right yes yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Joan Hambly yes
Jackie creation yes delicious partial
yes Tony Kaplan yes
just for months yes
Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman Bose
no
19 to 1.
okay by about of 19 to 1 this bill is uh
hb5 443 is judged to be
itl worthy of itl
so representative McWilliams you will
write the committee report
representative Kaplan representative
Kaplan will write the committee report
and even though I voted no on the motion
I do not intend to write a Minority
Report
I will close the what's this executive
session on House Bill 443 and we have
two left to do
ten past three
will open an exact session on House Bill
372 establishing a commission to study
the short and long-term impacts of
pending National and Regional carbon
pricing mechanisms on New Hampshire
citizens businesses
institutions and environment and the
chair recognizes representative notter
for emotion thank you Mr chairman I move
itl
chair recognizes representative berezny
I suck in that motion it's been moved
and seconded that we judge House Bill
372 to be itl representative Nutter is
recognized
thank you Mr chairman we can spend a lot
of time the rest of the afternoon
discussing this because this is a bill
that's on a topic that we've had over
and over and over again in this
committee I have my folder on this issue
is getting bigger I'm going to need
another part to it
and there's just so much to go through
um
I've saved testimony from people who
have come to testify on this bill in in
the other forms
uh New Hampshire is among the lowest in
the USA for carbon emissions less than
.0029 percent of the U.S total
how can anyone possibly rationalize
taxing people well in the other form of
the bill it was a tax and 80 800 million
tax hike it uh this topic was so
controversial that back when we were in
the minority it didn't even it didn't
even make it to to a house discussion
um the chairman at the time Bacchus
tabled the bill so he wouldn't have to
hear it
we had um
let's see I just I can just go on
forever here
oh I don't know how long you want me to
talk
needing your home and driving would be
your choice not mine is not is not a
nice to have in New Hampshire it's a
must-have that comes from Townsend
energy from Merrimack
there are several sources of that .00
to 9 percent
can I can I make a motion is that is
quoting testimony from previous sessions
there's any motion on the floor unless
you're having a man I make a point of
order there is no um
um
the motion on the floor is ideal you
can't visit you can adopt an amendment
not on the house sorry no no this is not
about an amendment is this is it
allowable to be quoting testimony from
previous sessions is that allowed to do
because it seems that what the
representative is doing is quoting
testimony from yes the the
representative is allowed to make any
comments that she wants as long as
they're within the bounds of what we're
discussing and as long as they're not
loot or lascivious
so continue representative not her well
well we just had so many interesting
things that were said at previous
hearings on the same on this whole
carbon tax thing
um
okay hearing word carbon carbon dioxide
is what plants need to survive and
without plants how are we to survive
there's another
um
on and on I could share this if you'd
like
I know it's a study but we've already
studied it so we're going to study the
study that we've already studied and we
keep doing this we keep studying studies
that have already been studied so why
don't we just not study it anymore and
just kill the bill
um thank you representative naughter
thank you
thank you representative merner is
recognized for a comment one of the few
times I'll speak um I was on that
committee that some of the subcommittee
that I set on to study this and to look
at all this we had numerous testimonies
from people around the country and just
for a point on this carbon pricing and
bills there was eight other bills twelve
other bills filed around the country
referendum questions even the state of
uh Washington Oregon Maryland and
they've all failed on this topic so um
all the stuff that we looked at we we
spent a lot of time we were in the
minority but I sat in on the committee
for the summer so
um
I think we I think we've studied this to
death but that's up to you people
I'm sorry when was that this the three
years ago representative Christian has a
comment yes I just have a little
confusion so my understanding of the
point of this bill is to study the
impacts of pending National and Regional
carbon pricing that it will have on New
Hampshire not on trying to make a
mechanism for New Hampshire but just
trying to understand what other
um legislation not within New Hampshire
um on this issue might
how it might impact us
that okay
thank you for that comment
it seems to me that there are no pending
um
National or Regional carbon pricing
mechanisms
that
are
awaiting adjudication the the U.S House
the federal government has a couple of
times tried to
bring a carbon tax forward and never
been successful and surveys of the
American public show that 60 percent of
Americans do not favor a carbon tax
so there is no pending National or
Regional carbon pricing mechanisms out
there
representative Kaplan has a comment
yes Mr chair uh with all due respect it
depends what you mean by pending I mean
there's uh huge support in the U.S
Senate for for carbon legislation uh the
Biden Administration is in favor of it
there are trading partners to our North
and across the water there already have
Regional carbon pricing mechanisms in
place and it's already having an impact
on New Hampshire businesses I think as
legislators we ought to be taking a
serious look at this just to be prepared
it's as the representative Christian
said we're not arguing in favor of a
carbon pricing mechanism inside the
borders of New Hampshire we're just in
favor of looking at what the impacts
would be should such a tax pass either
at the regional or national level
and it certainly is pending
representative Reynolds has a comment
yeah just follow up and try not to
repeat what representative Kaplan just
said my understanding of this bill was
to
that it would study the potential
effects of carbon pricing mechanisms on
New Hampshire citizens and businesses
for example if the European Union
implements carbon pricing or if Canada
implements carbon pricing
how would that affect
the economics of businesses that Import
and Export Goods so I see that there is
always some Merit in
understanding what may be coming
next year three years five years from
now and not simply saying you know we
studied it three years ago and we don't
think there's anything new because I
think this is carbon pricing is a
rapidly evolving
economic measure that probably won't
happen in New Hampshire but it may
happen elsewhere
representative Doug Thomas thank you Mr
chair uh simply stated
when we don't know what guidelines
National may or may ever have
or do I I just you know I believe is it
would be a waste of New Hampshire
resources to study a hypothetical
situation in terms of guidelines
when we don't know exactly what will
actually happen if it does happen at the
national level and if it is something
that
could
affect New Hampshire differently than
say the states around us and then I
think perhaps the study might be in
order but until then where we're
studying what might be and I don't think
we should use our resources given the
fact that we have 400 other Commissions
in the state so
um I can't support that
representative Christian has a comment
thank you chair
um I will say it since uh the last set
of of commissions in 2001 the IMF has
proposed a very specific International
carbon price floor proposal so that
might be one thing that we could at
least look at specifically
thanks
representative partial has a comment
yes to me it seems rather clear that we
can either keep this with a carbon tax
structure in place we can keep the money
in New Hampshire going to New Hampshire
citizens or you can pay this money
abroad in the form of tariffs and I this
think having the mechanism in place is
this prudence
representative munz has a comment
uh thank you Mr chair I just want to
Echo what some others have already said
that we're we're not
um
really debating the merits of a a carbon
tax or carbon trading system one way or
the other we're only talking about you
know understanding what the potential
impact would be and given the fact that
there are
carbon pricing mechanisms already in
place around the world
um that it would seem to me that it
would be
um appropriate to look at those
understand what the impact on New
Hampshire might be so that we could then
use that information to potentially to
hopefully advocate in favor of an
approach that's going to have the least
impact on New Hampshire rather than
waiting for something to be imposed on
us
and having to um you know fall in line
with you know something that might have
a pretty dramatic impact on our economy
and our our way of life quite frankly
further comment representative Corman
has a comment thank you Mr chair and I
want to speak to representative Doug
Thomas's point about uh that carbon
pricing uh mechanisms might be
hypothetical and why create a commission
for something that we don't know what it
is and I I understand that concern on
the other hand we do have some evidence
or there are there are carbon pricing
mechanisms in the world so we have some
concrete examples and also a commission
can create models that that will take a
range of parameters so that when carbon
prices are are a certain amount you feed
that into the model you get an idea so
even though we might not know the exact
nature of carbon pricing when it comes
we can at least be prepared for it with
models and going on what we already know
representative Carol Brown had his hand
up
uh thank you Mr chair and and thank you
to the rest of the committee for
listening to the the new person here's
the substitute on a number of these
bills I I noticed that at the very
beginning of them in this one in the
findings
they make General statements about what
the general court believes
and even though many of you support
what's being said in there I find that
those General statements
make a statement to the to the
constituents
that this is what we believe as a whole
and I don't agree with that
good point thank you for raising it
representative Wendy Thomas has a
comment yes thank you I would just like
to remind people that in this field in
this rapidly evolving field three years
is a lifetime and it would be prudent to
put a structure in place to for what's
coming down the road thank you
further comment
seeing none I'll ask a clerk to call the
question call the roll on the question
of itl for house bill 372.
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes
Andrew renzillo yes Troy Marner yes
Carol Brown yes well expiration yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom closure yes James
Summers yes Rebecca well McWilliams no
Joan Hamlet no
Jackie creation no lucious partial no
Tony Kaplan no
Christopher mons nope Henry Noel no
Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Corman no Ned Reynolds
no Cameron Bose
yes 10 10. buy a vote of 10 to 10 the
motion of itl or House Bill 372 fails
chair recognizes representative
McWilliams
um
I move OTP on HP 372 carbon pricing
commission thank you do I recognizes
representative muns second moved and
seconded that we judge HB 372 to be
worthy of ought to pass any further
discussion
representative Kaplan
yeah I'd like to present an amendment to
uh 372 that I spoke about
at the public hearing that is in order
what is the amendment number please yeah
you might already have it the amendment
number is 220
2023-0550h do you have that okay
everybody oh five five zero h
and this amendment simply uh adds two
new positions to the proposed Commission
one for the Department of
Department of energy the commissioner or
his his or her designee and one from the
Department of Health and Human Services
or his or her designee and the idea is
obviously the department of energy is uh
intimately concerned with the issues of
energy and uh ought to be at the table
for any discussion or any study of
carbon pricing and Department Health and
Human Services given their expertise
with public health and the potential
impact which is the scope of the study
the potential impact on public health is
contained in that study so they should
be also there uh the other thing the
amendment does is add a year to the
reporting period so that there's an
extra year to come up with a final
recommendation
is there a second to representative uh
kaplan's motion to adopt Amendment 0550h
representative partial
did you second it oh sorry
representative partial seconds the
motion of the adoption of
0550h discussion please
representative muns thank you I just
want to support the uh the amendment
obviously the department of energy needs
to be part of the process so I think
that's a that's a great addition and we
heard we heard pretty significant
testimony from some Public Health people
uh on the health aspects of um of this
and I think including the Department of
Health and Human Services makes perfect
sense and finally given the the
magnitude of the issue that we're
talking about I think an additional year
to complete a study is makes sense so we
support the amendment
additional comments
seeing Nana I'll ask the clerk to call
the role in the me on the amendment or
on the adoption of the amendment 0550h
to house bill 372.
Doug Thomas
go
Janine nodder no
Ender and Zillow no Troy Marner no
Carol Brown no Lex barajny no JD
Bernardi no Tom blochet no
James Summers no Rebecca McWilliams yes
Joan hamblet yes
Jackie creation yes lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes
Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas
Carmen yes Ned Reynolds yes chairman
Bose
no 10-10 by a vote of 10 10 the
amendment zero five five zero h
is rejected
so now we move on to uh
emotion of ought to pass as moved by
representative McWilliams is there any
further discussion on that motion
see Nana asked the clerk to call the
roll on the motion about to pass on
House Bill 372. we need a second to that
motion
it was seconded by representative
partial okay
sorry representative Munn seconded the
emotion
okay
all right
too many forums too fast
HB 372
OTP no Amendment
Doug Thomas
no
Gene otter no
Andrew and zullo no Troy merner no Carol
Brown nope Lex barajny no JD Bernardi no
Tom blochet no
James Summers no Rebecca McWilliams yes
Joan Hamblin yes Jackie creation yes
Lucia's partial yes Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas
yes Thomas Carmen yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman Bose No 10 10.
the motion of ought to pass on three
seven House Bill 372 fails
chair recognizes
representative Doug Thomas for a motion
thank you Mr chair motion to retain
here recognizes representative notter
I'll second the motion moved and
seconded that we retain House Bill 372
is there any discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of retained for
House Bill 372. Doug Thomas
no
Janine nodder no
Andrew and zullo no Troy Marner no Carol
Brown no Lex brajny no JD Bernardi no
Tom poche no James Summers no Rebecca
McWilliams yes
Joan Hamlet yes
Jackie creation yes lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Gorman
yes Ned Reynolds
yes
chairman Voss no
okay
by a vote of 10 to 10 the motion fails
the committee will not retain house bill
372. it will go to the house floor with
a recommendation without recommendation
I should say
and representative Janine notter will
write the itl position representative
Nick Williams who will write the pass
position
representative Kaplan representative
Kaplan will write the ought to pass
position on
house bill 372.
so we'll close the exact session on
House Bill 372.
331 we're down to the last bill
so I'll open an exact session on House
Bill 605.
and the chair recognizes representative
Doug Thomas
thank you Mr chair
motion itl
chair recognizes representative Bernardi
second the motion
it's moved and seconded that we itl
House Bill 605 FN
relative to solar generation under the
RPS
discussion on this motion
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
just that this is a very expensive uh
proposition over the years several
million dollars it wasn't the original
intent and also it only focuses on one
renewable uh as well so for those
reasons itl is in order
further discussion on House Bill 605
representative partial
yes I'd like to point out that the T-Rex
Bill we just passed earlier only focused
on one renewable as well
thank you representative Reynolds has a
comment
well thank you Mr chairman yes I'm the
sponsor of the Bill of course
um
commenting on the
fiscal note
representative Doug Thomas referred to
again that's sort of the
short-term
back of the napkin I mean I imagine that
Doe could have done that
calculation on the back of a napkin
during which they literally take the
price of
a rack and
multiply it by all the wrecks so not
really worth considering we've we've
heard that this committee lots of
testimony about the RPS and about Rex
uh
the point of having a renewable
portfolio standard at all is to
gradually increase the amount of
renewable energy
that utilities are required to
bring into the portfolio
over time
to increase fuel diversity reduce
exposure
to the fossil fuel Market
and hold down costs for consumers so
I focus this bill on a single renewable
solar on purpose just to so that it
would be simple
and clear
the gradual increase the numbers in the
bill are modest
easily achievable because they would
have New Hampshire do gradually over the
next two and a half decades what are
every other New England State around us
is basically already doing so there's no
question that this
um it's a not very ambitious bill but it
would have New Hampshire uh at least do
something in terms of positive force
bringing more renewable energy into the
Supply in New England
and reduce demand for precious fossil
fuels
and hold down prices so
opposed to inexpediate to legislate
further comments
representative Kaplan has a comment
yeah I I think it's so thank you Mr
chair
I think at some point we are going to
get tired of being the the donut in the
hole in the donut and being the flat
line in the regional uh pattern of
increasing grid penetration by renewable
energy while at the same time
piggybacking off the the benefits that
that penetration brings in terms of
lowering demand and therefore lowering
the rate of electricity and I find it
incredibly hypocritical that at the same
time that's happening we have people
here in in our house that will you know
shout to this to the skies about how
renewable energy is hurting us and then
when we have a bill like this one that
attempts to very reasonably increase the
flat line uh you know that we won't even
consider it I think that that's I'm
opposed to the itl as well
I couldn't support this legislation
and I dispute the
characterization by representative
Reynolds that this is a modest or
moderate increase
or representative kaplan's assertion
that this is relatively small this is a
huge increase remember these percentages
are the percent
of the utilities total
megawatt hour load that they must uh
purchase Rex for
and these are huge increases the fiscal
note
indicated in the first year alone it's
an 11 million dollar increase
and jumps all the way up to 46 million
dollars after just a few years
so the characterization that this bill
is somehow modest is
a stretch at best this is a very
expensive bill
and
I can't imagine why anybody
would want to go
would want to increase cost to rate
buyers by such a substantial amount in
the difficult
Market that we're currently involved in
there might be a modest increase to this
section of the renewable portfolio
standard that is acceptable but this one
certainly is not that
increase
representative Christian has a comment
I'll just re-up my comment from earlier
about all the research that's
been done being done to show you know in
some places in the country Renewables
are already much less expensive than
natural gas as they're on a learning
curve they will just continue to get
cheaper and cheaper fossil fuels are on
no such learning curve and all the
technological progress that is being
developed there is basically being
compensated for by the difficulty of
getting those in the ground
I I dispute that this would cost us
money in the long run this would
absolutely save New Hampshire rate
payers money in the long run and maybe
even you know
what are redefining as long run within
the few years we've seen natural gas
spikes
cause huge electricity spikes I don't
understand how we're debating this issue
um and also we've already hit some of
the targets and then some that we have
set so it's not quite such a stretch I
think as you're representing thank you
representative munz has a comment yeah
thank you Mr chairman I I I wanted to
follow up on on that comment a little
bit I mean I think if you it's important
to look at the uh when you're looking at
the the fiscal note that the 11 million
dollars that is quoted as predicated on
um an increase from the the um you know
what the current law provides of point
seven percent to I think the um the 2.5
percent increase
um but what it doesn't do is show the
where we actually are
um are we and are we above the point
seven percent now I believe we are
um and how does that compare to the 2.4
percent so the 11 million dollars we
we're probably you know we've probably
already
accomplished that objective so the cost
is going to be minimal and what it's
going to do is just
challenge us to go further
representative resident he had a comment
yes thank you chairman I just wanted to
respond to a comment a little bit ago
that uh we increased uh T-Rex and why
not increase solar but T-Rex can
generate energy whenever 24 7 if
necessary well solar only generates when
the sun is shining thank you
good point representative munz I want to
respond to your question about the 0.7
percent I was uh a co-sponsor on a bill
that raised those solar percentages 2.7
percent
uh two or three years ago along with
Senator Bradley and that's where they
are today 7.7 percent
representative Mark partial thank you
chair of owls you know I've heard this
argument again and again that solar does
not work at night
well well if we can use it during the
day to reduce our load we're saving
precious natural gas and we're driving
the price of a natural gas down and the
long-term benefit well to become more
affordable as it's in less demand it's a
simplistic thing to say oh the sun
doesn't shine at night we know that
further comment
representative not her doesn't shine
shine much during the day during the
winter either we don't have much
energy generated from our solar panels
this time of the year
representative Summers as a comment I
know that's not a popular comment but if
if the current Administration hadn't
stopped fracking for oil natural gas
it's on top of natural gas wouldn't be
as expensive either
representative Carol Brown has a comment
thank you Mr chair
um the first time I sat in here I made a
similar comment and representative
McWilliams you noted my passion and and
then thank you for that
so living in Bristol and having
Bridgewater
as my constituents and representative
berezny in Grafton County
and I apologize if I misunderstood the
comment here
I've heard this a number of times in
these hearings that it's only a small
change in the rape and you'll get
payback later on
a a large number of people in our
communities
can't afford
to worry about getting paid back later
on they can't afford to pay their bills
good point thank you
further comment
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question about of itl on
House Bill 605
yes
no
no no
no yes
by a vote of 10 to 10 the motion to itl
House Bill 605 fails chair recognizes
representative McWilliams for a motion
let's OTP this guy at 10 10.
chair recognizes representative muns
second
moved in seconded to judge House Bill
605 to be OTP any further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of OTP for
house bill 605.
Doug Thomas
no
Carol Brown no black expression no Eddie
Bernardino no
James Summers
nope
Rebecca McWilliams yes
yes
it was just partial yes Ronnie Kaplan
yes this month
yes yes
I'm a storm yes and Reynolds yes
please
no
and Tim
so by a vote of 10 to 10 the motion to
ought to pass fails
chair recognizes representative Thomas
motion to retain
chair recognizes representative naughter
second
moved and seconded to retain house bill
605.
discussion
saying Nana asked the clerk to call the
roll on the question of retain for House
Bill 605
no
no no
sure
yes
no I think it's good to go
delicious partial yes
Tony Kappa
yeah sure
no
yes
Wendy Thomas no
no
buy a vote of five to Fifteen the motion
to retain fails this bill will go to the
house floor without recommendation
representative Doug Thomas will write
the
itl report representative McWilliams who
will write the
OTP report
uh this is Ned Reynolds Ned Reynolds
okay
all right with that we'll close the
executive session on House Bill 605. so
who's doing
Doug Thomas is doing the itl
report
representative closure has a question a
question to the chair
um
House Bill 443
itl 1921 did a chair wish to put that on
consent
we cannot right it's a FN Bill
oh is it 233 no
if it's itl you can put it on
if it's an FN and it's itl that was the
vote then it can go on the consent
calendar I learned that yesterday in
ways and means
okay without objection we'll put HB 443
onto the consent calendar no objections
no objections okay that goes on to
consent
and uh
Tony Kaplan is writing the report for
that bill okay so let's review who's
writing what before we leave here
so starting with House Bill 233
that's an otpa and I will write the
report for that one
oh
yeah
either keeps scoring another piece of
paper I like how to shuffle always
sorry to create extra work for you but I
just want to make sure we walk out of
here with everybody knowing what they're
supposed to do
on these committee reports please have
them in my mailbox by noon tomorrow
first one is House Bill 233
which is otpa
and I'm writing the report
next one is House Bill 257 that's
recessed next one is House Bill 251
that's without recommendation
representative Thomas is writing the OTP
position
representative Doug Thomas that is
on 251
representative Reynolds will write the
opposing opinion on 251. oh so that's
otpa oh okay
quality
p a I wrote it down wrong I guess all
right so Doug Thomas is writing the
majority report and Ned Reynolds is
writing The Minority Report
is that correct
okay
263 FN that one was without
recommendation correct
and Rebecca McWilliams will write the
ought to pass position and J.D Bernardi
will write the
itl position
House Bill 281 also without
recommendation
JD Bernardi will write the
ought to pass position and Wendy Thomas
will write the
itl position
House Bill 443 itl Tony Kaplan writing
the committee report
HB 372 is without recommendation
Tony Kaplan will write the ought to pass
position and Janine Nader will write the
itl position
House Bill 605 without recommendation
that Reynolds will write the ought to
pass position and Doug Thomas will write
the itl position
House Bill 208
without recommendation
Doug Thomas will write the itl position
and
Jackie creation will write the OTP
it took me a minute to remember who what
JC stands for
Jackie Christian will write the OTP
report
and finally House Bill 298 also without
recommendation Lucas Lucius partial will
write the OTP position and Doug Thomas
will write the itl position
and then the last matter is the study
committee for house bill 257.
representative murder
is
appointed chair of that subcommittee
and he will be joined by representative
munz representative Corman
representative Wendy Thomas and
representative James Summers on that
subcommittee
and
I double checked to make sure
the only thing that's required for a
subcommittee to meet is 24 hours notice
so
all you have to do is post a note on our
door that says
HP 2 57 subcommittee will meet on such
and such a day at such and such a Time
and
that makes it so
so there's no waiting for a week
to get something noticed in the calendar
subcommittee work sessions do not have
to be noticed in the calendar
they just have to be noticed 24 hours in
advance on the door outside the office
so with that we're done and um
thank you all for your hard work today
hope you have a great weekend and it's a
long weekend so enjoy your Monday off
and we'll see you all back here on
Tuesday for one public hearing and a
whole bunch more executive sessions
see you then take care